(Connor clapping)
- Congratulations, you've made it.
- Congratulations.
- You've made it to the
"Trash Taste" episode.
- Congratulations.
(Garnt making bird noises)
(Joey laughing)
(upbeat music)
- Welcome to this
episode of "Trash Taste."
Hope you guys are doing
well and enjoy yourself.
Have a nice seat, get comfortable.
Get a little popcorn or
something, I don't know,
'cause we're gonna the movies.
(all laughing)
- We're gonna the movies?
What are we seeing, dad?
- What is this, POV?
You're on a date with Connor.
I'm like, "Yeah, get
yourself comfortable."
- We're gonna the movies.
- On a date with the boys right now.
- I don't know what else to say,
all right, all right?
(Garnt laughing)
You got me, okay?
How you guys doing?
- It's good, it's November,
where the fuck has this year gone?
- Oh my God, dude.
- And I can say this, because this is...
We don't have the buffer anymore.
(Joey chuckling)
So whatever we talk about,
I mean, we're filming this on Tuesday,
and it's gonna go out Saturday,
which is, I think the first
time in "Trash Taste" history.
- Little over, when the
"Trash Taste" episodes,
a meta reference.
- So it's a shame, there's no, like,
hot topics to talk about.
I don't think there is any, recently.
- I watched the "Dune"
movie, is that a hot topic?
- I don't know, not really.
- I mean, people are talking about it.
- It's a movie.
- Yeah, I saw it.
- How was that?
- Fucking amazing.
- [Connor] Really?
- I genuinely don't understand,
like normally, right?
online, okay?
- [Connor] Okay.
- People love to be critics
about movies, right?
- No.
- You go onto Rotten
Tomatoes, you go onto IMDB,
all sorts of self-acclaimed
critics, right?
- Yeah.
- And you know, most of the time,
I'm okay with opposite opinions,
'cause, you know, I always wanna know
like what the opposite opinion is, right?
It's like, okay, if I
really enjoyed something,
right?
- Where you going with this?
- Then I wanna see, like, how bad it is?
Like if I really hate
something, I wanna know,
you know, why people
might've enjoyed it, right?
I'm usually open to it.
I think this might be
the first time in my life
where I don't understand
the opposite opinion.
Because I saw so many people
on like Twitter and like Rotten Tomatoes,
like, rating "Dune" is like,
"Oh, it was shit, it
was a disappointment."
I'm like, "Did you watch the
same movie that I watched?"
Because it was genuinely the
first time where I'm like,
"I actually don't
understand your criticisms."
Like, is that weird?
- Why are you brain-dead?
- Were you asleep during the movie?
- So what about it is so good then?
I mean 'cause I'm gonna watch it.
- Oh, yeah, same here.
- But I've been watching,
like, every other movie,
except that movie.
- So like, for one,
it's like one of the...
So I'm like a massive fan of the books.
- Okay, I haven't read the books.
- Okay, but that's all right.
- Can I still enjoy it?
- Yes, absolutely.
So I went with a couple of my friends,
one of them has read the books,
and the other two hadn't
read the books, right?
So it was good to find out,
if you needed to be a
fan of the books or not.
Luckily everyone enjoyed it.
- [Connor] Yeah.
But I think it's because the
movie did a really good job
of like picking and choosing,
like, the right information
to leave in the movie.
- [Connor] Okay.
Because there's a lot of
information from the books,
that they didn't include in the movie.
- Naturally...
- I mean, that's just
how book adaptations are.
- I mean, "Dune" is like...
especially "Dune" is like,
so fucking extensive
when it comes to its law.
Like, literally the first
book, at the back of the book,
there's a literal glossary of terms
that you need to understand,
- Wow.
- To read the book.
(Garnt laughing)
Like, that's how it...
- So it's just like,
its own terms that it's made up of.
- Its own terms that it's made of.
- Okay.
- Like Frank Herbert, who's
the creator, was like so light.
He was so fivehead, with this shit,
because like, you also have to understand
this was written in, like 1965.
Like, it's a 50-year-old sci-fi book.
- It's that old?
- [Joey] It's really old.
- Wow.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I've heard it's like visually
and the sound is amazing.
- Oh, Dude, like,
I'm gonna...
This might be a hot take,
but I think it is one of Hans
Zimmer's best soundtracks.
- That is some fine works,
'cause he's had some amazing soundtracks.
- Like, I thought--
- The boom guy.
- Yeah.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
The boom...
- The boom guy.
- Every Hans Zimmer one has the boom,
or something like that.
- I love Hans Zimmer...
- I could be wrong.
- Yeah, I love Hans Zimmer,
like "Lion King" soundtrack, epic.
"Inception"...
- He did "Lion King" ?
- Yeah.
- He did "Lion King?"
- Yeah, he did "Lion King"!
- What!
- You didn't know he did the "Lion King?"
- No.
- Yeah, Hans Zimmer did
the "Lion King" soundtrack.
- Thought it was Elton John.
I am joking.
(Joey laughing)
- He solo carried.
- No, he did the "Lion King" soundtrack.
- No fucking way.
- Yeah.
- Are you serious?
- Yup.
- He actually...
- To be...
To be fair...
- You could fact-check,
but I'm pretty sure...
- To be fair,
with "Lion King,"
I don't remember the soundtrack
as in like the background track.
I remember Elton John.
(Joey laughing)
- Just goin ham.
- He did go ham on that.
- To be fair.
- Yeah.
Yeah, but he did, you
know, he did "Lion King,"
he did "Inception", he obviously...
Basically, every Christopher
Nolan movie, he did.
And I thought he peeked at
like, interstellar, right?
Like, that's like the one
soundtrack, everyone says,
it's like, "yeah fucking
amazing movie soundtrack."
- So what would you give
the movie out of 10?
If I dare ask for your score.
This archaic system,
- Out of 10?
- Of judging movies.
(Joey laughing)
- I'd give it like a strong nine.
- Oh, wow.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Well, I'm just gonna watch it.
- Yeah, I was gonna watch it
because the biggest criticism I've heard,
if you can even call
it a criticism, really,
is that, so much of it depends on...
- [Connor] Number 2, right?
- Dune, part 2,
- Yes.
- Because I've heard
it's not a full movie.
It's just...
- It covers the first half
of the first book.
- Yeah.
- And it's a two and a half hour movie.
- Well, when they release "Dune 2",
they probably will do the whole,
you can watch the first
movie before the second one,
you know,
- Like a bundle package.
- Like they did with the "Avengers".
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah, you can watch "Infinity
War" before "End Game".
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What I've heard about part 1 of "Dune"
is that it's not like say, you know,
"Avengers Infinity War" or like "Lord...
- It's not trying to
build a whole world...
- Yeah, where you don't get,
like, a natural story arc,
it's just, you get half a story.
- Yeah, I've heard its abrupt,
yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, it does kind of just end...
- I can see where that
would piss people off.
- Yeah, and I think as well,
the other big thing is that, I feel,
a lot of the criticisms I saw is that,
I think, they kind of almost,
gave it a little bit of false advertising
with, like the trailer, because
I watched the trailer of it,
and there's like, you know,
it looks like an action Sci-fi.
- But the thing is, "Dune"
is not an action sci-fi,
it's a political sci-fi.
- Yeah, that's one of the
things where it's tough
that you can't market politics.
Which is like, which is why...
(all laughing)
- Which is like, why...
- Your fans are crying.
(all laughing)
- I am sure you can market...
- Where is my politics?
- I mean, you can market politics
but in a movie, it's
kind of hard to be like,
"And then he signed the
paper, making the agreement."
(Joey laughing)
- Yeah, I mean, that's just like,
a lot of mecha anime, in a nutshell,
people were just like, oh,
giant robots go pew, pew, pew.
And then it was like, "Wait a minute,
I'm really invested in these colonies
and the politics of these colonies."
- "What is all this government bullshit?"
- Oh, its like "Game of Thrones,"
you don't tell someone "Game of Thrones"
is like a political thriller
of backstabbing and stuff.
You're like, it's got dragons and zombies.
- [Joey And Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- Exactly and then...
- Because I watched the trailer
and literally the entire trailer is,
it's like 80% of it is a lot
of like, fighting scenes.
But what's funny is that, like, all of,
like, all the fighting
scenes in the trailer
are all the fighting scenes in the movie.
- [Connor] Okay.
- Okay.
- [Connor] All right, okay.
- And, so, I--
- I'm not gonna watch the
trailer now, it's just spoilers.
- Yeah, no, so I can see why, like,
I think people might've been,
maybe like, misinformed about it,
if they never, like read
the books or anything.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Maybe, I don't know.
- Since living in Japan,
I've been doing this thing,
where I just don't look at
reviews, before and after.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Full stop.
I just do not look at reviews anymore.
I just look at the
movie, I watch a trailer,
I'm like, "It looks okay."
- [Garnt] Yeah.
Or even sometimes I don't
even watch the trailer,
I just pick one.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I just go to the cinema and I watch it.
I've been really enjoying
movies a lot more.
- I think that's smart.
- I think that's
the right thing to do.
- Yeah, that's
the right thing.
- It's hard because
sometimes I watch a movie
and I'm like, "I think that was good,"
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
but I need someone else to
also tell me it was good.
- Right, right, right.
(all laughing)
- Because that's the days we live in.
- I experienced that recently with,
I'm sure, I don't think we can spoil it,
but we were asked to watch
something by a company,
right?
- Yeah.
- And it was the first time--
- Did you have to make that so obvious?
(Garnt laughing)
- Okay, but it was the first time
that I had watched something.
I got like, given early
access to something.
So even if I wanted to,
there is no way I could
check, whether this...
What I was watching was good or not?
- And I can't wait to talk about that.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, we were gonna
be talking about that
on another episode,
but it was like such a weird
experience for me, to be like,
"Huh, I think this is good."
I am like, "My opinion,
I think is right, but..."
- Doesn't it suck...
- It could be wrong.
- Doesn't it suck that,
at the end of the day,
it just boils down to, I
liked it, but is it only me?
- Yeah, I think that
I've started to, like,
from doing this a lot.
I've just, because now I
don't treat movies as, like,
"I wanna watch that one film that's good."
It's like, "I wanna just do
something for three hours."
That like, lets me shut off.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So I'll just go to the
movies, watch anything,
literally anything.
- My problem with movies right now is that
I have such a short
attention span, like I--
- It's the one place
I can, like, shut off.
- Like, 'cause I need, I
wanna shut off in the movie,
but I need to know that
it's worth my time, right?
That's like, it's like
taking a leap of faith.
And the thing is, if you
take that leap of faith
and the movie ends up being good,
then you enjoy it way, way more.
But I just have like,
I don't have the attention span
to sit through enough shitty
movies, that I'm just like,
"Okay, I'm just not in the mood for this."
- Yeah, I'm not sure what's
changed, I know why I'm like...
- Because, I'll tell you
what I've been doing actually
to offset this, which, I know
you think I'm a psychopath,
which is whenever I get recommended
random clips on YouTube,
for a movie I haven't watched,
I see that clip, and sometimes
it's like a banger clip,
and I'm just like, "All right,
this movie is worth watching."
I'm gonna watch the entire movie.
- So you have to basically watch like,
a portion of the movie before you're like,
"I'm ready to watch the whole thing."
- There needs to be something
to sell me on this movie.
It doesn't even need to be
like a high scoring movie
or something that people
like, everyone recommends,
there just needs to be
something about this movie
that I'm just like, "Okay."
- A hook.
- Is there no part of you,
that just wants to turn up to a movie
and know nothing about it
and just watch something?
- Oh, yeah, I mean,
I think that's the issue of
watching things for a job.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
Where, I watch enough things
for a job, blind, anyway,
that, where in my free
time, in my downtime,
I want to know that this
shit is worth my time.
- I get that, I get that.
- Because if it's not,
then it's just another job.
- I understand that.
It's weird because even
if the movie isn't as good
as I would like it to be,
I still get the same level of enjoyment
from just being in the environment,
getting to experience watching something.
Even if it's shit, I'm like, you know...
- I think you just like
the cinema experience.
- I really do, and also
I just like having,
sometimes it's nice...
It's nice watching something,
- [Garnt] Yeah.
that's bad, so I can have
a frame of reference.
- [Joey] Right.
- It could be like,
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] This is...
- If everything I watch is good,
I have no idea what's bad anymore.
And this is why, I think,
I've relied on reviews,
'cause I only ever watched
the things that were good.
- [Joey And Garnt] Yeah.
- And I feel like,
the more I've just been watching stuff
and making my own opinions,
the more I'm kind of enjoying the process
of then just being like,
"Okay, what do I think about that movie?"
I'm not not looking at anything else.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- It's weird, I don't know,
'cause I definitely did feel
that I was so spoiled watching everything
that was quote unquote good,
that it was getting to the point
where I'm like, "All right,
I say, this must be, I don't know,
this must be a weird take."
I'm just like, "What is good anymore?
I don't know."
- I mean,
- I get that.
- I watch enough shit things for my job.
- [Connor] Right, you're used to...
- For me, like, there's nothing
that grinds my gears more
when I watch something
and I feel like it was
just a waste of time.
Like something that's not entirely good,
but not even that bad, it was just...
- Yeah, the mediocre ones are the worst.
- The mediocre ones, I'm just like,
"I could've done so many
things with that time."
- Which is why you would
never go out of your way
to watch a five or a
six out of ten, right?
- No, no.
- But if you turn up at a
cinema, you don't know what it is
and you watch a five or six out of ten,
you're like, "No, okay."
- But I'm not the kind of person
who just walks up to a cinema and goes,
"I'm just gonna watch something."
If I'm at a cinema, I'm
there for a specific movie.
- [Connor] Wow, I'm the opposite of that.
- For me to go to a cinema,
I am committed to whatever I'm watching.
- Movie theater, for you Americans?
I know, fuck it.
- No, because like, to me, yeah, I get it
because if you're in the movie
theater, like, you're just,
you're committed to be there.
And I've only ever walked
out of one movie in my life.
And that was...
- Which was it?
- Live action "Ghost in the Shell".
- [Connor] Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, yeah, that's right.
- And that was just
because I was just like,
I watched about 40
minutes and I'm just like,
"This is neither good, nor bad.
This is a waste of my fucking time."
And I like, I went
there by myself as well,
so I'm like, "No commitments,
I am just going to walkout."
- I'm trying to think what movies,
I watched "The Last Duel" recently.
Do you guys have heard of that movie?
- Nah.
- What the fuck is that?
- All right, so exactly, right?
So all--
- Is that a recent movie?
- Yeah, all I knew about this movie,
is that it starred Adam
Driver and Matt Damon.
That's all I knew about this movie.
I knew that it was kind of based in like
the 13 hundreds or something.
- [Joey] Right.
- So it turns out the
plot is about something
where there was a famous rape case
in the 1300s in France,
and it was kind of like
unheard of that there would be,
you know, a court trial
around something like this.
And then it ended up in a duel.
And the whole movie of this thing
is like telling the
perspective of each person
involved in the rape.
- [Joey And Garnt] Right.
- So it's like the woman's perspective,
the guy during the rape and
then the husband of the woman.
- [Garnt] Right, right.
- That he rapes.
And it's obviously like the 1300s,
so the rules are all like
totally fucked and obscene.
- [Joey And Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- You know, and it was...
it was good, but it was
also like really weird.
'Cause we're supposed
to be like 1300s, France
and just Matt Damon was there,
and like an American
and then--
- Not even like--
- Is this a new movie?
- Yeah, but,
and then like Ben Affleck was there.
- Were they doing like a
French accent or anything?
- No, no, just American,
(Joey laughing)
but it's just kind of like...
- Okay.
- It was the first time in my life
where I'd ever genuinely felt
like a movie was bogged down,
by having actors I knew.
Like, I was like, this
is just like, I just,
I don't need to see Matt Damon.
- Because you can't un-see Matt Damon.
- Because, I'm watching
this movie and I'm like,
there could have been
so many better people
who could've done this role.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Also, you know, if it was in French,
I wouldn't have cared.
Obviously, it wouldn't have got the budget
and obviously, you know,
that kind of stuff.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- But like, I don't know,
it felt weird, 'cause then
there was like, American
and then super British dudes
and then some dudes with French accents.
And it was like this whole
weird thing where I was like,
like, I think the movie was good,
but also there was just like
the casting felt really weird.
I didn't really know what to think,
and then I did go online and
it was like 8.5 or something.
And I was like,
- [Joey] Really?
I was like, "okay."
I mean, "I guess that makes sense."
- Do your opinions get skewed
when you see online reviews
and like, when you have
your initial opinion
and then you see the reviews
and then you...
- Yeah, definitely.
- Do you think your like
opinion gets skewed, a bit?
- Um, sometimes.
- Sometimes
I'd love to tell you I'm immune,
to my opinion being...
- Yeah, yeah.
Everyone out there watching,
is just like, "Other people's
opinion do not affect me."
- Yeah.
- I have my opinion and that's
that and I'm just like...
- I think, for most things,
it doesn't affect me,
but then there are times again
where, like similar to your
situation, where it's like,
"I'm not sure if I enjoyed it or not,
so I need like a second opinion about it."
- I need someone to tell me.
- Yeah (Garnt laughing)
I need like a second opinion.
- "Bro, bro, back me up,
this was a good film, right?
This was a good film."
- You know, and the film
is very uncomfortable,
and you know, it's kind
of hard to watch at times,
but then I'm also like,
"I guess that's the point
though, that's the idea."
This is not supposed to be fun to watch,
but then I'm gonna the movies
to pay for watch something.
And so, I was in this weird
spot where I was like,
"This could be a four or an eight
and I don't know which one it is."
- [Joey] Right.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But I like public consensus.
- So it's one of those
kind of movies,
- One of those movies.
And I left it thinking like,
"Okay, I think it was an eight,
but I just wish the casting was better."
I didn't read anyone else's reviews.
I just saw the score.
- [Joey And Garnt] Yeah.
- I don't know, maybe people
disagree with me on that,
but I was like, yeah, I
was just like, whatever.
And then on the opposite end
of the spectrum, I was like,
I'm gonna watch James Bond.
(Joey laughing)
It was like, I know everything about this.
I've read all of Daniel
Craig's weird ass interviews.
Have you seen that man's interviews?
- [Joey And Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- What the fuck is that man on?
- Its so funny.
- Have you seen some of
the shit this man's saying?
- It's so funny.
(Joey and Connor laughing)
Daniel Craig articles that
were better than the movie.
(Joey laughing)
Reading these articles,
I got like 10 times more
enjoyment, reading these articles.
Did you read the article
where he was like,
"I kiss everyone on set."
Did you read this article?
- [Both] No.
(Connor laughing)
- I need to read.
- This article--
- Give your homies a little smoochie.
- Nah, da da, da da da,
it wasn't just, it wasn't,
"Give your homies a smooch."
It was like, oh my God, all right.
- Say, I am Bond, James Bond, agh.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Daniel Craig and Remi Malek's claim
the pair kissed on James Bond shoot.
"I'm a very friendly guy," in quotes.
- Like, who said this, Rami Malek?
- Daniel Craig.
- Okay.
- Malek said Craig grabbed
him and picked him up
after he shared a good idea for the movie.
It's so weird.
- Like, you genius.
- It's so bizarre.
"He grabbed me, picked
me up in the moment."
"He grabbed me, picked me up,
and I can't tell who
initiated the next moment,
whether it was him or I,
but a kiss transpired between
the two of us," he said.
- Well, what kind of kiss?
- He said, "I'm gonna say Daniel Craig,"
I need to know how much.
- Yeah.
- How intense was the...
- Yeah, yeah.
- Was there tongue?
- Was it like a full Frenchie
or like a little peck on the cheek?
- Was it like Sonic and Mario
making up, kind of deal?
Or were they like, rip the clothes off?
"I'm gonna say that
Daniel Craig initiated it,
and I was very taken aback."
He added that the kiss was very welcome
and that, at the time, he asked Craig,
"So does this make me a Bond girl?""
(all laughing)
And then, this is a
quote from Daniel Craig.
"I kissed him, all right,
I kiss lots of people,"
Craig said.
(Connor chuckling)
"It's like, I'm a very friendly guy
and I wouldn't rank anybody."
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
"That would be a terrible thing
to do."
- Ranking.
- To rank the best kissers, I would,
I would just, how many
people could I offend?
Terrible, thousands of people."
- My God.
- What's going on on
the set of James Bond?
- He's just go around
to every actor and like,
"Have I kissed you yet?
Not sure"
- Going around like just Frenching people.
(all laughing)
That's not the audition process.
You know, "You're suitable for the role.
Now, okay, okay, get Daniel Craig in."
- This article is insane.
"Listen, this story's had
legs about kissing Rami.
I've just been trying to get it more legs.
I don't know if it's on social media.
I haven't got social media,
but I said, I used to kiss
Rami at the end of every scene.
This is like, it's just
like not a big deal.
God almighty, just spreading the love."
Malek,
(Connor laughing hysterically)
Malik, quipped,
"I would just rush through scenes,
just to get to the moment
that you would get kissed."
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
What's going, what's--
- Wait, so, is like Rami Malek into it?
- He's loving it.
And the whole set is loving it.
- Sounds like a fucking
love story going on here.
- The director is like,
definitely, pushing through
one take wondering--
- It was just kinda like,
why don't you just like, just fuck.
(all laughing)
It was just such a bizarre read.
I was like, "What is going on?
Why are they sharing this?"
- It sounds like an onion article.
- I love it.
- I watched James Bond,
Daniel was nothing like that.
- I watched James Bond and
I was just imagining him
at the end of every scene.
I just imagined him just running off
and going and making out with Malek.
(all laughing)
I love it, I was like,
"This is the best article
I've ever read in my life."
I was laughing my ass off.
- [Joey] So funny.
- And like there's countless articles
from Daniel Craig before
this movie came out,
are just like, insane.
- Just losing his mind.
- Just saying the random-est shit.
He just brought up the one time,
he was like, he only goes to gay bars
because it's more friendly or something.
And I was like, what is--
- He's not gay though, right?
- No, no, he's like, I
feel more safe there,
other people won't try
and start fights with me.
I'm like, "What are you doing?
Why you are getting in
fights, in every bar?"
- I mean, he is James Bond.
- Yeah.
- I know, but he's like 50, man.
- Is he's just like method acting?
- I don't know, man, I was like,
"You're going to gay bars,
you're kissing Malek"
I'm like Craig, man, come on, let us,
come on, just, what's going on buddy?
Like, you want me to say it,
like, it's cool, it's cool, dude.
It's 2021 bro, like, it's fine, right?
- I think it's gonna be
my favorite Daniel Craig
clip though, you guys know?
- The Weekend, yeah.
- Ladies and gentlemen.
- Okay, and there's--
- The Weekend.
- There's another article
where he didn't know about the meme,
and they introduced the meme to him.
- Yeah.
- And he's like,
"That's great, that's amazing."
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Like, Daniel Craig articles
are better than the fucking movie.
The articles are 10 out of 10,
the movie was a five out of 10.
- Yeah.
- That's kinda how I see...
- No, did you watch the movie?
- Yeah, yeah.
- The time to kill, was it?
The new one?
- To die.
- "Time to Die."
- Time to die.
- It was all right.
- Yeah.
- It's fine.
- I mean, I dunno.
- You should do a movie
Snapchat, or whatever.
- I'm not even really like
a fan of the Daniel Craig,
James Bond movies, like any of them.
- "Casino Royale" is good.
- I think that "Casino Royale"--
- Skyfall was okay.
- I think, he more like,
peaked at "Casino Royale"
and then--
- It's a shame that it
was like his first movie.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- After that he just--
- Well, that's when they like
really re-imagined James Bond.
- Yeah.
- I was like,
never really had like a
massive fan of James Bond,
but obviously, I just feel like
it's just not as massive
a franchise as it was
when, you know, we were growing up
when our, like our parents' age.
- Yeah.
- And I think like,
especially you'd said about
like the Matt Damon movie,
which I somehow haven't heard of,
like back in the day if Matt
Damon and who else was in it?
- Adam Driver and Ben Affleck.
Like, it was a good movie.
- Yeah, I mean, these
are like A-list actors,
and I remember back in the
day, if they were in a movie,
you'd fucking hear about it.
But nowadays, I feel like movies...
It's weird 'cause movies aren't sold
on their actors anymore, I feel like.
- Well no, there's this amazing
interview at Comicon with,
I forgot what the name of the guy is,
guy plays, the guy with
Iron Man, he's like, friend.
- John Favreau?
- John Cheadle?
- Not John Cheadle.
Oh, another (indistinct).
Wait, now, wait, what,
who, wait, it wasn't him.
Who does?
He's a superhero.
Anthony Mackie.
- Anthony Mackie.
- Oh.
- [Man Off Camera] That's falcon.
- That's Falcon.
- Falcon, that's who he was.
- That's not Iron Man's best friend,
that's Captain America's best friend.
Come on there partner, get it together.
- The widest picture.
- Wide Anthony Mackie.
- Actually, there's a,
so what's the quote?
So he did this formal
interview at Comic-Con,
and it came on my recommended at one point
and it was him just basically
explaining how like,
you know, like Stallone, Schwarzenegger,
don't sell movies anymore.
It's the superheroes that sell movies.
Like, nobody cares,
I mean, they do care about
the actor who plays it,
but it's not the actor who brings in the,
maybe Robert Downey Jr.
- [Garnt] It needs to be like
It needs to be like the right actor.
'Cause back in the day you
could just hire an actor
for a role.
- Just like, what was that?
What was that dreadful
movie that Robert Downey Jr.
did with like, it was like
Dr. Dolittle, but like.
- Oh yeah.
- And like it bombed.
- Yeah, I remember
- It was right after Endgame.
- Yeah.
- His first like, big movie, apparently
was this awful "Dr.
Dolittle" kind of version,
and he was trying to do like
a Welsh accent or something.
- [Man Off Camera] It
was a Dolittle movie.
- Was it a re-imagining of "Dr. Dolittle"?
- [Man Off Camera] It was a remake.
- Yeah, I think it was a
remake of "Dr.Dolittle".
- It was like these movies
that don't need remake, "Dr. Dolittle".
- 'Cause the thing is,
yeah, Robert Downey Jr.
was massive as Iron Man,
but at the same time,
I think, Robert Downey Jr. was
just acting Robert Downey Jr.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- [Man Off Camera] He was
great in Sherlock Holmes,
just saying.
- Yeah, Sherlock Holmes...
- Yeah, but that's because
he was (indistinct)
just playing a British version of himself.
- You know, like it's,
it's like the movie
culture I feel has changed
and people care more
about concepts nowadays.
'Cause like, even with
something like "Dune",
that's a massive like,
new movie franchise.
I don't actually know
any of the actors in it.
Even though I know there are
some famous actors in it.
- There's some famous actors,
- Is Zendaya in it?
- [Man Off Camera] Timothee Chalamet.
- [Man Off Camera] Zendaya.
- Yeah, Zendaya's in it.
- Oh yeah.
- But like I, yeah...
- That's not the reason
you're watching "Dune".
- Oh, Jason Momoa's probably
the biggest one that's--
- Oh yeah, Jason Momoa's in it.
- Yeah.
But that's like, not the
reason you're watching--
- [Joey] No.
- You know, so, in some ways,
I'm kind of glad that it's straight away
from the actors sell
movies, not the movie.
Like it kind of is, you know,
it means that we hopefully
get different actors for what,
we still don't really but,
there's more chance that
you'll go to watch a movie
because people say--
- Because of the concept.
- Not because Stallone's in it.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- Like, I don't know,
like, I was never really,
I don't know if this is 'cause of like,
different generation thing,
but I never really cared
about the actor in it.
- No, I didn't either,
I mean, it sold movies.
- I am for the character.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, exactly.
You know, the performance is good, great.
That's good for them, but...
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- And it's a bonus if it's
like an actor that you like
or an actor that you know is
like perfect for the role,
but it's like, I'm not gonna go watch...
The only one I can think of
is like a Nicholas Cage movie.
- Yeah.
- I'll watch him because
Nic Cage is in it.
- But that's like a meme.
That's just like watching
an Adam Sandler movie.
- Yes, exactly, exactly.
- Now, Adam Sandler's
like the only guy now
who can like sell movies by just,
being--
- Being Adam Sandler.
- Literally just being him.
He's literally like the
only guy who could like
make a career of just,
fuck, like being like lazy.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Just like doing anything.
- [Joey] That's true.
- You know,
even then he fucking
killed it in "Uncut Gems."
I'll say this for like
the 10 millionth time.
Watch that goddamn movie, it's amazing.
Do yourself a favor,
and you need to do yourself
a favor, watch that.
- 'Cause like, I had this
thought the other day,
'cause I was like, on the
topic of celebrity culture,
I was like,
do you think there's gonna be someone
who is going to be as
famous as Michael Jackson is
in our lifetime, again?
'Cause I feel like--
- Probably.
- Hmm.
- You think so?
- Probably.
- I don't know, I don't
think there will...
- Who do you think is the
most famous person right now?
- Kim Kardashian, unfortunately.
- You know, I actually googled this
after I had this thought.
Do you know who is
ranked as the number one
most famous celebrity?
- Lets think again.
- Wait, wait, wait, wait...
Isn't it like fucking, it's
a footballer probably, right?
- No.
- Really?
- Cristiano Ronaldo, Lionel
Messi were in the top 10 though.
- What's the occupation?
- Actor.
An actor?
- Yeah, I was surprised.
- I wish it's Adam Sandler.
- Number two was Donald Trump,
which was not surprising.
- Right, right.
- Now that I think about it,
but number one really surprised me.
- Male, female?
- Male.
- Male, male actor.
- Hold on, I can think.
- Yeah, I can think, yeah.
(Garnt laughing)
- I didn't intend this
to turn this into a quiz.
- Brad Pitt?
- No.
It is Dwayne The Rock Johnson.
(Man off camera laughing)
- Oh, yeah. Okay, yeah.
- No way.
And I'm just like, is he that famous?
- No, he is, he is.
- Is he?
- Yeah he is.
- Like, internationally?
- Yeah.
- Isn't he's like one of the
most like highest paid actors?
- Yeah, yeah, he is.
- 'Cause like, "Fast and Furious" movies
are like everywhere.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Everywhere.
- He's also one of those actors
that looks and feels natural
in like an adult film,
like "Fast and Furious",
but also in like a Disney film.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- You know.
- Is "Fast and Furious" an adult film?
- Well, I mean, compared to like "Moana".
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- It's not a kids movie.
- Yeah, that's true.
- He's also,
you know, I mean, so you will,
but like having a recognizable
face and figure, is like,
definitely a part of it.
- Yeah, that's true.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And just his name's The
Rock, you know what I mean?
People are gonna remember that.
- The Rock.
- Dwayne The Rock Johnson.
(speaking in Japanese accent)
- What surprised me is
that he wasn't like,
he wasn't the first
person to come up to mind,
when I think of like a
famous person, right?
- Yeah.
- But he is just--
- But he's also one of those guys where,
if you say the name, then
you're like, oh yeah, of course,
yeah, you know, like, "Yeah, he's famous."
- It's definitely easier
when you have like a
name that's super easy.
- Yeah, that's true.
Dwayne The Rock Johnson.
- That is also a cool name, right?
- Yeah, it's cool.
- The pain.
- It's more like catchy
than just Dwayne Johnson.
- Yeah, because like,
especially like, traveling
around the world now,
you realize that people are just like,
like there's different levels of famous,
depending on where you are on the world.
- Cristiano Ronaldo is
like, known everywhere.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- Yeah.
- Football's massive except for
probably like the US, right?
That's probably like
the biggest place that--
- But they all probably
know Ronaldo still, right?
- Maybe.
- Do they?
I dunno, Americans, do you
know who Cristiano Ronaldo
and Lionel Messi is?
- I know at one point,
David Beckham was like
the most famous person on Earth.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You don't think he is now
'cause he hasn't really--
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- But I swear like 10,
20 years ago, he was
the most famous person.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, because--
- Bend it like Beckham phase.
- [Connor] Oh, my God.
- Well,
it's weird to see how celebrity
culture has evolved, right?
Because I'm like,
how I got onto this thought was I remember
I got recommended a clip of
a Michael Jackson concert,
and it was just literally like,
Michael Jackson standing up on the stage,
standing still.
(Joey laughing)
And then people are just like
passing out in the crowd.
It's fucking insane.
- Yeah.
So there's this concert,
there's a really famous concert,
it's on YouTube, right?
The opening, right?
- Yeah.
- The lights come on,
and then from the stage,
there's like a trap door that opens
and Michael Jackson literally shoots out.
- Like, emerges out.
- With some sunglasses
and he's standing there.
And I swear for 10 minutes,
this crowd is losing their fucking mind.
- There are people like...
- He literally just stands there.
- The literal clip on YouTube is called
Michael Jackson Stands
Still and People Pass Out.
- Yeah.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
He's not even moving.
- It's fucking insane.
And it's just like insane to think that
like he was, back in the day,
he was put up to like
almost godlike status.
I mean, I can't imagine someone today
having that kind of reaction
or anyone today having that kind of a...
- I mean, I feel that way as well
whenever I look at, you know,
like Beatlemania clips from like the 70s.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly, right?
- People losing their mind
to The Beatles, right?
- It's BTS now, right?
- Oh.
- You think so?
You think so?
- I don't think it's to the
same level as the Beatles high.
- I think the thing is, I
dunno, I think BTS is in line.
- The BTS fans are like,
oh, challenging accepted.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I think it's the closest thing
we've had to that level of like intensity.
- [Garnt] True.
- But I don't think
we've had any--
- I think though the thing
is it doesn't look as intense
because a lot of that is all online now.
- [Connor] That's true.
- Whereas back in the, during Beatlemania,
like, if you wanted to go see The Beatles,
you had to go, physically to go see them.
- [Connor] That's true.
- I think another thing is
that you just know way more
about the celebrity, nowadays,
because of social media,
and it's like, it kind of
like humanizes them more
than before, when your
only exposure to them
was through like,
news media and TV and like--
- Like interviews
and stuff like that.
- Yeah.
And that was the only slice
you got, behind what was,
what their lives were.
And now, you know about everything,
like, you know, the good and the bad.
Like I remember, it's so weird seeing,
like, for example, Chris Pratt,
I remember when everyone
fucking loved Chris Pratt,
he was like,
(Connor laughing)
he was like the golden child.
- Yeah, he was.
- Of the internet.
- Do you mean now?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- No, he's not.
- No,
and then suddenly people
just started hating him.
I can't remember what set it off.
I didn't even know why...
- Really?
- It might've been the,
I remember he did like a
lot of Christian remarks,
a lot of people like, were
not like, happy about that.
- Yeah, oh, okay.
- Oh, okay.
I guess I missed that arc of Chris Pratt.
- Yeah, I missed that arc, I just like,
one day I woke up and it was like,
it was cool to like Chris Pratt,
then I woke up on another year
and everyone was suddenly hating him.
- And now it's cool to
like Chris Pratt again.
'cause he's getting everyone--
- I could be mistaken on this,
I know that a lot of
people got annoyed at him
around the time of like,
I think when James Gunn got fired?
- [Garnt] Yes, yes, yes.
- And everyone from "Guardians
of the Galaxy" like,
tried to like, openly like
supporting, you know, James Gunn.
I think Chris Pratt didn't
really do anything in that,
like, kind of rubbed people the wrong way,
or he gave some vague
Christian-esque statement
that people didn't really like.
- [Joey] Right.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I know that was around the time,
when I first started seeing stuff,
people like, didn't like Chris Pratt.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You know, I mean,
it's all, you know, the
internet is like that.
- Now you can't stop
hearing about Chris Pratt,
'cause not only now he's he Mario,
but he's also Garfield, as well.
- I can't believe...
- Is he Garfield?
- He's voicing Garfield.
- Wait, what?
When did this get announced?
- Today.
- This morning.
- Oh, shit.
- So like, the real MVP
here, Chris' agent is like,
fucking...
- [Joey] Oh, yeah.
- Who the fuck is that agent?
(Joey laughing)
This man is insane.
- In his ways.
- Bro, this agent, man,
he better keep him on lock, man.
This agent is...
- Could you imagine if, just like,
your agent just walked in and
was like, "Oh, by the way,
you're gonna be voicing
Mario and Garfield."
- Next up, next up,
you'll see it, tomorrow,
he's voicing Gru from "Despicable Me".
He's taking over Steve Carell, move aside.
He's not as marketable anymore.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
My God.
- Like this morning,
especially on Twitter,
I was like--
- Why's he Garfield?
- And also did you hear as
well that they're making--
So you know how Seth Rogan
is playing as Donkey Kong?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, Donkey Kong is getting
his own movie, as well,
that's been confirmed.
- As Seth Rogan?
- As Seth Rogan.
- Fuck off.
- Yeah, that was confirmed as well.
- Fuck off, you're lying.
- Unfortunately.
(Joey sighing)
- This is...
- It was the weird timeline
I woke up to this morning.
I'm like Seth Rogan, Donkey
Kong is getting his own movie,
and Chris Pratt is Garfield.
- What's going on with these movies?
- This is like the proof
that we live in a parallel universe.
(Joey laughing )
Like, we've like, somehow,
like we've jumped timelines
and we've not realized that
we've jumped timelines.
- Yeah.
- Do you want the Mario movie to be good?
- No.
(Joey sighing)
- Why no?
- I see--
- Define good, define good.
- Yeah.
- You want it to like legitimately be
a critically successful--
- Do you think the "Sonic" movie was good?
- I actually liked the--
I like the "Sonic" movie.
- I feel like you should go
into like that kind of realm.
- Okay, where it's like critically,
nothing to really get,
- Yeah, it's just fun.
- But it was good fun.
- Conceptually, it was fun, yeah.
- Yeah, I, yeah, yeah.
(Garnt laughing)
Yeah, what do I want it to be?
- I just don't know what
to think about it, I guess.
- I just can't put my, you know how, like,
when you hear the "Sonic"
movie and it's like,
you can kind of figure out, "All right,
I can kind of understand,
where they would go with this
cast and these characters."
That makes sense
- [Garnt] Yeah.
With the Mario thing that
they've announced so far,
I think, the reason why
everyone's freaking out,
'cause everyone's like, "What
the fuck is this movie?"
Like, "What are they doing?"
- [Garnt] Actually, it goes...
- What actually is this movie gonna--
- It goes against what we
just said, where we said,
celebrities can't sell a movie.
(Joey laughing)
They fucking sold me on this,
they sold me on the "Mario" movie.
- They sold me, but like,
I'm like, there's no
way this can be a movie.
Like an actual thing.
- [Joey And Garnt] Yeah.
- What's so surreal
about the "Mario" movie,
is that it's a fucking meme.
It is a shit-post that got
made into reality, right?
- How is Donkey Kong as Seth Rogan
gonna contribute to this plot?
I don't understand, because
Donkey Kong rarely contributes
to any-fucking-thing in "Mario".
He's kinda just chilling--
- The one I'm personally
excited for is Keegan,
playing as Toad.
- How is...
How is that gonna come into this?
How are they gonna
introduce Keegan, as Toad?
How does that happen in the movie?
I'm thinking, I'm sitting here
and I hope this ages poorly or something.
I'm so confused.
And like, even now, like,
and then the real Mario voice
actor's gonna cameo, how?
How is that gonna happen?
- [Joey] That's what I am wondering.
- Is he just gonna say,
"It's a me, "Mario"
and Mario is like, "Fuck it."
- "It's a you, Mario."
- Is he gonna say--
- "It's not a me"
- Pranks gonna be like,
"No, it's a me, Mario."
And then like, they
have this weird fucking
rush hour three-esque, stupid thing.
Like, is that what's gonna happen?
- I don't know.
Like, the entire thing
could be like a new grounds,
parody animation from like
2010 or something, you know.
- It's like an OneyNG.
- Yeah, right, except
it's the fucking reality.
- And then it's by Illumination, as well,
which is also like "The fuck!"
Like, I don't know what's going on.
- What have Illumination done?
- "Despicable Me."
- Oh, okay.
- And that kind of, those kind of movies.
- Did they make the "Emoji" movie as well?
- No, that was Sony.
- Okay, okay.
- Sony movies...
- Luckily, no.
- Sony movies, ah...
- Ooh.
- Well, they had like,
"Into the Spider-Verse",
then they were like, ton of backtrack.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I think it's different for
different studios and stuff.
- Yeah, I mean,
I think that was a different studio
and then "Into the
Spider-Verse" is kind of just,
its own anomaly, you know,
'cause there's no other
animated movie, I think,
that is just like "Into the
Spider-Verse", 'cause its,
- No.
- Such a unique--
- Still haven't watched it, and I wanna--
- You haven't watched it?
- See, here's the thing, right?
I really, really, really wanted
to watch it in the cinema
and I just didn't,
and then now I really wanna
watch it, but I'm like, "Fuck,
it would just do a
disservice to watch it."
- I thought--
- Just so, you just never
gonna watch it then?
- No.
- You never.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- It's probably like, it's one
of the best animated movie.
- I don't give a shit about
Spider-Man, but I loved it.
- Or maybe one day,
I'll just go to like a,
I'll find a really rich
friend and I'll be like,
"Can I go to your home cinema?
And can we watch "Into the Spider-Verse"
'cause I've been like holding off on it?
Like, could we do that?"
I don't have any friends
with a movie theater-thing.
Maybe face (indistinct).
- We'll make one.
- The Trash Tastes Movies.
- Trash Taste Movies Theater.
- Well, let's move the Trash Tastes studio
to like, Arkansas or something.
I bet like, we could get like,
a big plot of land there.
- Yeah, probably.
(indistinct)
- Yeah, then we can get a theater there.
Arkansas fans, what do you say?
- Yeah, one thing, I'm so jealous,
whenever I see American set up
their studios of their house,
it's just, like, they've
got so much fucking space.
- Oh, yeah.
If we paid the amount we're
paying for this studio,
in America, we'd have,
like, quadruple the space.
- Because, like, even in,
like, living in England, as well,
we don't get space in
England, as well, you know?
Like our houses compared to Americans'
are like, fucking tiny.
- Although they are bigger than Japan.
It's like, where I put Japan,
UK is 20% bigger and then 80% is--
- What would you say, Japan or Tokyo?
Because there's two different things.
- But even outside of, you know,
you go to the countryside in Japan, right?
And you'll see these, like,
giant sprawling fields.
You'll see four tiny houses,
just right next to each other.
They don't want any privacy,
they decided, "Fuck privacy."
They're like, "The rice
fields need more room."
Because that's what the countryside is.
It's like 90% rice fields.
- But with the amount we're
paying for this studio,
if we were like way outside in Japan--
- [Connor] Oh, true.
- We'd probably get, like, at
least double, triple space.
- Some of those houses, they're
giving them away for free.
Some of them are, like,
a hundred bucks a month.
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
- I mean, like, the
housing market in Japan
is, like, not the most
healthiest thing in the world.
I mean,
(Connor shouting)
that's what happens when you
have a declining population,
right?
- Yep.
- Yeah, so people are
literally giving away houses
in some places?
- That's interesting,
'cause Japan's government
is just, like, "Yeah, it's a problem."
And then it was like,
"What are you gonna do?"
Japan's like, "Yeah, it's a problem."
(Connor and Garnt laughing)
- That's another social
issue in Japan, actually.
- No, they say,
no, they go, "Oh, it's a problem,
what are you gonna do about it?"
Like, "We'll make the
old people live longer."
- They're, basically.
- Up the healthcare.
- Their kids will stay in
the countryside, right?
- [Joey And Garnt] Yeah.
- Right?
- People wanna stay in the countryside.
- Will they have a job? I dunno.
- It's really interesting 'cause
it's one of those problems,
that, like, where its,
you can't have a platform to campaign on,
being like, "Yeah, I'll fix the problems
that's gonna come in 30 years."
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Which is all politics, I guess, really.
- Yeah.
This episode is sponsored by Express VPN.
- Going online without Express VPN
is like using your smart
phone without a case.
(Joey and Garnt speaking
in foreign language)
- Most of the time,
you'll probably be fine,
but all it takes is one accident drop
onto solid concrete
(Joey gasping)
to make you wish you
had protected yourself.
- Nightmare fuel.
- Every time you connect
to an un-encrypted network
in cafes, hotels, airports, anywhere,
your online data is not secure.
- What?
Any hacker on that same network
can gain access
(Connor gasping)
and steal your personal data.
- Are you serious?
- I am serious.
- Fuck, and it actually doesn't take
much technical knowledge
to hack someone.
- [Joey] What?
- Just some cheap hardware is needed,
a smart 12-year old could do it.
And Joey, don't forget,
your data is valuable.
- [Joey] Is it?
- [Connor] Hackers can make
up to $1,000 per person
selling personal info on the dark web.
- But luckily, Express VPN
creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device
and the internet so
that hackers can't steal
your sensitive data.
It would take a hacker
with a super computer
over a billion years to get
past Express VPN's encryption.
All you have to do is fire up
the app and click one button
to get protected and you
can put it on your phone,
laptop, tablet, and more, so
you can stay secure on the go.
- Do you use Express VPN, Connor?
- Of course I do, every day.
So secure your online data today,
by visiting expressvpn.com/trashtaste,
that's E-X-P-R-E-S-S-V-P-N
.com/trashtaste,
and you can get an extra
three months for free.
expressvpn.com/trashtaste,
links in the description below.
- [Connor] Wonderful.
- Back to the episode.
But no, yeah, I saw the
"Matrix" trailer, as well.
And, you know, when,
- Oh, have we started?
- I guess so, you brought up the "Matrix".
- Oh, yeah.
- So Joey brought up,
seeing the "Matrix".
- Yeah,
I saw the trailer for the
"Matrix Resurrection",
I think it's called.
- Yeah, yeah,
I'm gonna be honest with you,
I've watched all the "Matrix" movies,
and I cannot remember what
happened in any of them.
- Me neither.
- I kind of have,
because I went on a stint
of watching "Matrix" clips,
like for some random...
- Not the movies.
- Not the movies, the
clips and I'm just like,
I think the second and
third movie were way better
than what I remembered, 'cause
I was watching these clips.
- Really?
- Yeah,
I was watching the clips.
This is just how I
experience movies, nowadays.
- Garnt literally doesn't watch movies.
Garnt watches one fifth of a movie,
and decides if he likes the movie or not,
and then never watches it.
- I can't believe we're
about to live vicariously
through you, watching clips.
- 'Cause, like, I just watch
the best parts of the movies.
(Joey laughing)
The great thing about watching
the best parts of the movies
is that you get to blank
out, all the shit--
- Makes the movie look way better.
- It just makes the movie look way better.
So I remember saying in our movie episode
that I don't think the
"Matrix" has aged well at all.
- Yeah.
- And I think,
there was like so many
little things that I didn't
really understand when I first
watched the "Matrix" trilogy.
- Mm-hmm.
- Right?
- Apparently, the co-director
said that it was a metaphor
for being trans, the whole movie series.
- What?
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Well, I mean the,
Wachowski brothers did--
- I mean, they are the Wachowski sisters--
- Yeah, they are the sisters, so yeah...-
- And it was a metaphor about being trans.
- I'm trying to...
Did that pop up in any of the clips?
- I don't know, I, you know, again,
this is just saying I read and I was like,
"Oh, I didn't know that.
- [Joey] Oh, okay.
- Okay, cool, I mean, I didn't know.
- Yeah, I mean,
what I found was really cool,
was how the entire world,
was kind of, like, built,
like, you know, like a program.
And I didn't realize at the time
when I watched it as a kid,
that basically every character,
like, represented a different program
or a different subsystem of the "Matrix".
And I'm just like, "Oh,
there was so much thought,
that went into this
about "Matrix" law, that just
fucking flew over my head
as a kid.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm just like, "Oh, cool,
people go bang, bang, bang,
pew, pew, pew."
- Yeah, slow-mo, yeah.
- Yeah, and that's all I care.
- Bang, bang, bang.
(Garnt laughing)
- That's all I cared about as a kid
and I realized when I was
like watching these clips
and like watching videos
about "Matrix" law
and like how and what--
- Did you watch a 10-hour YouTube essay
about why the "Matrix" is
good and you should care?
- No, I watched--
- That was only about four hours.
- No, it was two hours, actually.
- It was only about four hours,
thank you very much.
(Connor and Joey laughing)
I needed someone to tell me
what to think about the movie,
because...
(Garnt chuckling)
- That's why I watch "Gigguk",
to get down with anime.
So do you think it needs a new movie?
Do you want a new movie of "Matrix"?
- I mean, I wasn't expecting
it, but you know what?
I am curious, if I were to be honest.
- I know if it makes Keanu
happy, I'm fine with it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I think there is space for a new movie.
- [Connor] Okay.
- The problem is, I don't
remember how the third movie ends.
- The third movie ends, spoiler alert.
- For a 20-year old movie.
- Yeah, for a 20-year old movie,
with Neo and agent Smith fighting.
- Yeah.
- And you know,
they're doing, like, the Superman shit.
- Yeah
- And then Agent Smith,
like, I forgot, like, what he, like,
puts his hand into Neo
who becomes agent Smith and
then Neo dies, because--
- Right, right, right, right.
- And then--
- And that was it.
- [Connor] Epic.
- And then humans and
machines live in harmony
and the "Matrix" is saved,
(Joey snickering)
and that's it, then it's remade.
And I think that's the movie.
- So how would you go on, from that?
- Well--
- Good question.
- I can't remember what the
trailer of the plot was.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's just very confusing.
- Yeah, I just think there is like,
because, that's what got me into it,
because I saw the trailer.
Now, I remember, because I was, like,
"How are they gonna make a fourth movie?"
And so that got me to look
into the original trilogy.
- This is why I go on
uploads once a month.
(all laughing)
- I'm like retracing my steps
to why I started watching "Matrix" clips,
and it was because of the fourth trailer.
And I think there is space
because there is space
for more storytelling
with different iterations of the "Matrix".
And I think that was one
really interesting part
of the "Matrix"
that was never, been able
to, what was never explored
in the original, which was,
this was just one version of the "Matrix".
- Yeah,
- So there were like,
there could be plenty of others
and there could be plenty
of others in the future.
So there's so many ways you can--
- So what you're saying is
it could turn into like
a "Fate" situation.
- No, no, no, no,
(Joey laughing)
I did not say that.
- Okay, that was Joey.
- That was Joey.
- You said there were multiple universes,
multiple timelines,
and all I could think of
was, oh, it's just like,
it's like "Fate".
- There's a moon,
- Yeah.
they have a moon.
(Joey gasping)
Oh my, okay, so,
I wanna watch the movie,
- [Garnt] Yeah.
but I understand that I have to go back
and watch the other three.
- Yeah.
I don't think you do though.
- No, really?
- No.
- Oh, really?
- I kind of want to, though.
- But I feel like, I've missed
so much point of the movie,
but then also re-watching
the other movies,
you can't not pay attention.
It's one of those movies,
you look away, your phone for one second,
you're like, "Rewind that
two minutes, please."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah, I do wanna watch it.
- Yeah, I mean, it was a different,
it was a different experience
going like revisiting the "Matrix".
Like, I kind of realized
how much of an amazing
character Morpheus is, now.
And that makes me really sad,
that they didn't get Laurence Fishburne
to come back as Morpheus--
- [Connor] Oh yeah they--
Even though they got like the main--
- Is there a reason why?
- I think because they're doing
young Morpheus, in this one.
So
- Ah,
I mean, it might be,
might be a plot point.
- But he was in "John Wick".
- I don't know.
- He was in John wick.
- Was he in "John Wick"?
- He's in John wick.
- Is he in "John Wick"?
- He's in "John Wick".
Yeah.
- Oh.
- I did like that Keanu Reeves
basically just--
- Looks like "John Wick".
It was just basically "John Wick".
- He's given up and I love that, though.
Like, I'm gonna contradict
myself to my point earlier
where I said that I don't watch
movies 'cause of the actors.
I will watch almost
anything with Keanu Reeves,
just because he's such a delight to watch.
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- Like, he does just have...
He always, you can tell he loves it.
- It's also a colder
thing that in real life
he's also really chill.
- Yeah, yeah.
You know, I know it's like the thing
you do on, when you're, on the internet
to just adore Keanu Reeves,
but like legitimately,
like when he's on screen,
I love watching him.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- I genuinely feel that he loves
every second of performing.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah.
- And it's just a delight to watch.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Sometimes it's just nice to see someone
who loves something that they do.
- It's like saying, love
someone who loves their job.
- Oh, I don't know, it's
the little things in life.
- He's just, even when he's
doing these characters,
you can just tell, like, through it.
- Yeah, yeah,
- I don't know why.
I don't know how you can
do that, but it works.
- I don't know why but Keanu Reeves
seems like the kind of guy
who would, like, collect
merch of the movies he's in.
(all laughing)
- He's like that kind of guy, right?
It's like, "Yo, I've got this
"John Wick" action figures,
fuck insane.
- "John Wick" is like
some of my most enjoyable
theater experiences.
Like, every single time
I've gone to watch it
in the movie theaters, I've
just had such a fucking delight.
- I've only seen the first one.
- Honestly.
- I've only seen
the first one as well.
- Yeah.
- Please watch the other
two, they're so fun.
- Oh, yeah.
- Really good movies.
(Garnt laughing)
- Watch "John Wick".
- Just go watch "John Wick".
- Watch "John Wick" for a day.
- Yeah.
Do you know what realization
I had the other day,
as you guys are talking about movies?
- Yeah.
- So I haven't been watching
movies recently.
I've gone back to watching anime now.
- What?
- I know, I know,
I finished my seasonal
video and I'm just, like,
I feel like continuing some of these shows
out of my, own volition.
- [Connor] Pride.
- What did you watch, Garnt?
What did you watch?
- No, I just had this
realization the other day.
- Ah, I like anime.
(Joey laughing)
- No, well, one, yeah,
I actually like anime,
and number two,
so I finished watching
some of these episodes
and I'm just like,
(Garnt sighing)
I don't have anyone to talk to this about.
- Oh, no. (Joey laughing)
- Once again in my life.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I am sorry."
- I realized that everyone
in my life around me,
doesn't watch anime anymore.
And I'm just like,
"Am I the last motherfucker
who still watches anime?"
(Joey singing "Mad World"
by Michael Andrews)
- I just watch, I watch
normie mainstream anime.
I don't watch...
- If it's not on Netflix,
Connor doesn't touch it.
- Listen, I'll watch it.
If it's off of Netflix, I'll
just begrudgingly do it.
I'll be like, "For fuck's sake."
- 'Cause it...
- Okay, go, go, go, go.
- It was so weird,
because, like, when me and
Sidney started our relationship,
we'd like, this side of
our relationship was like,
we'd watch like a new show or something.
- Yeah, yeah. -
- Between us.
Like every, you know,
every time we had some free time
and now I'm just like, "Honey,
you wanna watch an anime?"
And she's like, "No!"
"Show me a, put on a shitty horror movie.
That's what I wanna watch.
Let's put on 90 day fiance."
And I'm just like,
- "Get that Japanese shit outta here."
Eww.
- And I'm just like, "Okay."
So I started my YouTube journey
having no friends around
me who watched anime.
Then I found--
- Too many.
- Too many friends who watch anime,
and I'm just like, every
time I hung out with friends,
everyone around me watch anime.
- Yeah.
- And then, now, I moved to
Japan, started an anime podcast,
I'm dating a girl, who,
I'm going to get married to a girl
who was a big weeb, an anime fan,
and no one around me
fucking watches anime.
What the fuck is going on?
I've literally looped back
to where I started off at.
- Those who don't learn from history
are doomed to repeat it, right?
- This cycle of a weeb.
- It is so surreal now, though.
I know more people who've watched anime
and who were like, heavy anime fans.
But are now just like,
now just like more integrated
into, like, the weeb culture
or like the wider anime culture,
without actually watching anime.
It's so weird.
- You know that meme where it's like,
the floor is,
and it's like the meme,
it's like the floor is watching anime.
I'm like, literally doing everything,
but watching...
(Joey laughing)
I've been reading, like, books, recently.
- I feel like...
- Wait, what?
You've been reading books?
- Books, with no pictures.
(Joey gasping)
I would talk about it, except
I haven't finished them.
- Pics or it didn't happen.
- I'm reading a few of them.
- What kind?
Like, storybooks, information books?
- Like, fictional,
nonfiction, autobiograpy?
- Ah, non-fiction.
- Just give us a taste.
- Non-fiction.
- I'll talk about when I'm,
I'm halfway through one,
that's really good, right now.
- Okay.
- It's about Japan,
and it's really good,
I'll talk about it later.
- Wow.
- Something good.
- Something's like, okay.
- But it's like literally,
the floor is anime,
and I'm like, fucking
jumping in the air, like.
- What timeline are we in?
- I don't know, man.
I'm reading.
- Connor's reading a book,
Chris Pratt is Garfield.
I'm not watching anime.
- I feel like we are in
the "Matrix" right now.
You know, all the signs you look for,
to, like, see if the world
we're living in is fake.
I feel like there's enough
going on around me right now,
but I'm just like--
- We're in the "Matrix".
- All right, stop the simulation.
I know that...
(Connor laughing)
Get me out, get me out.
- Connor read a book,
I'm gonna kill myself,
'cause I'm in a simulation.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Yeah.
I watched, actually I
didn't tell you about this,
I watched an anime on
the plane back to the UK,
and I watched eight
episodes and I stopped.
I was very angry.
- [Joey] Yeah.
I watched, was it?
81, 87, was it?
- 86.
(all laughing)
- Bro, It was shit.
- Was it?
- It was bad.
- You didn't like it?
- I thought it was bad.
- I've heard really good things about it.
- Bro, it was--
- Like, literally everyone,
I know says its amazing.
- What was bad about it?
I like it.
- What'd you like about it?
- I mean, I just liked the concept,
it's been so long since we've seen, like,
I feel like it's the
closest we've had, to, like,
one of these mega shows
that I watched growing up,
at least,
where it was like two nations
going against each other,
and then there was some mystery going on
and you didn't know--
- Did you like the mystery?
I was so bored by the mystery.
I was like, "Okay, whatever."
And then the whole time--
- Don't look at me,
I haven't seen it.
(Joey laughing)
- The whole time, they were
doing the whole thing of like,
you know, obviously, racism is bad, right?
I get it.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But when they like
spoonfeed it to you, like,
"Racism-bad, huh?"
- It comes here and it's like,
- "Agh, racism!"
And its like, all right, I get it, right?
It's like, such an unnuanced take about it
that I was like, "Okay,
all right, we get it."
- I get that.
Yeah, I was just so, like,
I was so bored by it,
I was like, "I get it," right?
I don't need you to tell
me that this is, like,
this is the story, like, this is...
And I should feel sad.
- So they were like, over-explaining it?
- [Connor] To me it felt,
- I mean, it was very,
it was very much put in your face.
I mean, the entire thing
was basically based around World War II.
- But it was kinda like, nudging, like,
"Huh, is it bad?
Huh?"
And it was the whole time watching it.
I was just so bored.
And I was like, and the
whole mystery aspect to it,
I was not enjoying it.
So I, "Should we roughly explain
what the plot of the show is first?"
- Sure.
- What do you remember?
- Okay.
- I'm very curious.
- This has been a month.
It's been two months,
(Garnt laughing)
since I watched this
and it was on a plane.
- I love it when Connor
tries to describe an anime.
- There is a main MC who is a...
Everyone in this world, right?
Is in this beautiful homogenous society.
Everyone is the same,
has the same hair color,
and same, you know,
everyone looks exactly...
- Everyone's white.
- It's Aryan bro, they're all Aryan,
that's literally what
they're trying to do.
- Just say that.
- Okay, then, they literally were like--
- They are all white, just say that.
- But it's anime Aryans,
so they have green hair
instead of, you know.
(Joey mocking sarcastically)
And so they're in this world
and everything's perfect.
And they keep doing this
fucking stupid thing,
where they're like, and it was just like,
it was so obvious what they were tryna do,
where it was just, not happening.
I was just like, "Okay, we get it."
They were like, every
single day, they'd be like,
"We have zero casualties in
this war, isn't that amazing?
Zero casualties, zero casualties."
And the whole point of it is that
they have these mechs that are fighting,
and they're piloted by the other people,
who are not the perfect race.
- [Joey] Right.
- And they make them fight in the mechs.
- Peasants.
- And they have, oh yeah, peasants.
Peasants, guys.
And they have these mech, like, captains,
these are the captains
that talk to the peasants,
God forbid they have
to talk to them, right?
Somebody has to talk to them,
in this world.
And our main protagonist, guess what?
She's sympathetic to the
peasants, as they say,
I'm calling them peasants,
I don't know why, I've caught the cold.
Garnt said peasants,
(Garnt laughing hysterically)
so I'm running with it now.
- They're called the peasants now.
- So obviously she's sympathetic,
and she starts to become
friends with them.
- [Joey] Right.
- Oh, turns out,
these other race of people,
they're just normal human
beings, who would've thought?
You know, it's just like,
"All right, come on, man."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like, come on!
- It does sound pretty dumbed down.
So like, it's like,
I don't know, like a Disney
movie take on it, you know?
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It was just so,
it was like Dr. Seuss.
Like "Cat in the Hat"
level of talking about--
- [Joey] Right.
- I was just like, so
I already get it, come on,
we're in 21st century now,
we can do more nuanced takes about this.
- I'll tell you like a perfect analogy,
which will, I think
you'll understand, Joey.
It feels like,
a Gen Urobuchi show,
without being written by Gen Urobuchi.
So
- Yeah, okay.
- Explain that to me.
- I get what, exactly
what you mean by that.
- Okay, you get it now?
- Yeah, yeah.
- You get it?
- Yeah.
- Okay, now explain that to me.
(Joey laughing)
- Okay, so Gen Urobuchi is the
guy who wrote "Psycho-Pass",
who wrote "Madoka Magica"
and "Saya no Uta".
- "Saya no Uta".
- Well, "Psycho-Pass",
I thought was amazing
and like a really good take
on the whole societal aspect of that.
But like, this just felt like--
- Yes, but that's what he means.
It's like a show that's
written by Gen Urobuchi,
but not...
- But worse.
- Yeah.
- But like, not as nuanced.
- Am I? Do you think it's bad?
Do you think my opinions on this--
- I mean, I think, yeah,
I think you actually
have the correct opinion
where it's like very spoonfed into you,
like, racism is bad,
and that's never why I kind of liked it.
I kind of liked more,
I kind of more gravitated
towards like, the mystery aspects
of just like, 'cause one thing,
one big thing you missed
is they're at war,
so this nation is at war
with another nation, right?
- I could figure out,
roughly what was going on.
- Yeah, yeah,
and the other nation has robots
that are completely autonomous.
Like, they have technical,
they have a technology
that is way more advanced
and they have AI robots that
they're fighting against,
except, the nation that we're following
has human robots, right?
- [Connor] Right.
- So apparently, the nation is like,
I can't remember the exact details
'cause I'm not up to date,
but apparently, the nation
has a time limit, right?
And after this time limit is over,
then the robots are going to shut down
'cause there's no one
actually telling these robots
to fight.
- And then if they like,
year about Y2K, probably won't happen.
(Garnt laughing)
Yeah, but, like, I was more, like,
what drew me in with this,
was more the mystery aspects
and more like the character dynamics
between the main girl and
the and the group itself.
- I agree, but at times,
the character dynamics
did feel real predictable
and stale, for me.
It was just kind of like,
I wanted to know more about the enemy
and I wanted to learn
more about the mystery,
but everything else was
such a slog to sit through.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- That I was just like--
- Is it maybe because it's a concept
that you've already seen in anime before?
- It couldn't be that, it
could also just be like,
I just didn't feel like,
although the mystery
aspect was quite good,
all the other aspects didn't
really entice me, personally.
You know?
And also I was on a plane,
so it was the choice of like,
I can try and get some sleep here
or I can continue watching the show.
And it was really struggling,
every episode I kept going on,
I kept thinking it's really going--
- You know, it's not a good sign,
when you have to choose between
watching the next episode and sleep.
- I really wanted it to pick up the pace.
Like, it was really like
taking it's fucking time.
And they really--
- That's something I agree on.
- They really, like, wanted to show
that the main character
was sympathetic, but like,
it was obvious, she was sympathetic
and they just kept doing things
to show that she was
sympathetic, over and over again.
And I was just like, "I get it."
- [Garnt] Yeah,
- We get it.
We all know, we get it.
- There's lots of
sympathetic MCs out there.
- And like,
it was just so frustrating
watching the show
where they just had the same
copy and paste, like, action,
where she would talk to
someone, they'd be like,
"Oh, don't talk to the peasants."
And then she'd be like, "But I like them."
And then she would literally
have this conversation
with everyone.
And yeah, okay, maybe that
would happen in real life
if the situation was real,
but it was just so boring,
they had to show it every goddamn time.
We get it, it's not normal.
- I also think it was bad
timing that this came off,
came out after "Attack
on Titan", which is like,
I think a way better,
- Yeah.
- Way to show some of the
themes that "86" was showing.
- That's true, that's true.
- I think "Attack on Titan"
was kind of like a masterclass
in that sense.
- It's like, it took
aspects of "Attack on Titan"
and weirdly "Code Geass" in
some sense with the whole,
Britannian and all that stuff.
- [Joey And Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And didn't really land
it with any of them,
for me personally, like, I
didn't feel like it nailed it,
but it got a second season,
so clearly it must have been--
- Well, I mean...
- I've heard...
- The second season is like
the second half of the story,
so it's kinda more, like,
just a continuation.
- Yeah, I've only just
heard good things about--
- There, we spoke about anime, okay?
(Garnt laughing)
Okay, I'm moving you
two to go on more anime,
whatever you want.
- Yeah.
- Do you think I've been watching anime?
- Joey watching anime?
- Joey, get out of here.
- I do wanna watch...
- Yeah.
- I do wanna watch "Platinum End" though?
I do want to watch.
- Why?
- 'Cause it looks edgy, it looks fun.
- Oh, it is edgy.
- It looks dumb and fun.
- I've heard the ending of
that is like really bad though.
- Yeah, yeah.
- In terms of like--
- But it looks fun.
It looks like the high rise invasion shit.
Like, it looks like it's bad, but also--
- Is that what you look for nowadays?
- You know, I'm trying not
to be picky with anime,
because if I'm gonna be picky,
I'm gonna be like Joey and
I'm not gonna watch anything.
- Yeah, pretty much.
- 'Cause Joey's read all this shit,
but I haven't read this,
so I'm like, I need to just stop reading
about stuff too much, and just
pick something, and watch it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But then I did that
with "86" and I hated it.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I mean, that's the give and take.
- But that might happen
with "Platinum End".
- That's true.
- Yeah.
- But then I feel like if
I've at least done that,
I can, then, at least, if
I get to eight episodes
and I stop,
I probably have more to say
than if I watched 12 episodes,
and be like, "Eh"
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
I have more to think and I
have more to say about it.
And then I can go onto the anime podcast
and talk about it.
- Why don't you watch,
like, something, like,
I don't know, Komi-san?
Why don't we do a thing
where we--
- I don't think,
you'll enjoy Komi-san.
(Joey laughing)
- We all--
- Komi-san, like,
Connor watching Komi-san?
- I wanna hear Connor
talking about Komi-san.
- We should do an anime review,
like once a month
where we all have to
watch one different anime
and present it like a book club.
- Oh, that's so much effort.
- Joey's not gonna do that.
- Not like--
- Can I do like a manga review?
- No.
We gotta push an anime
'cause we're an anime podcast.
(Garnt laughing)
We're fucking talking about it.
- I don't even think
our viewers want that from us, honestly.
- It's funny 'cause people will like,
people will have like,
95% of viewers who I swear, are like,
"I get bored when they talk about anime"
And there's 5% of viewers are like,
"I hate when they're talking about anime."
- [Garnt] Yeah.
I fucking hate them,
they call themselves the anime podcast,
what a fucking joke!
- I feel like our viewers have become
like everyone around me,
which is everyone was an ex-anime fan
and now everyone just
finds himself watching
anything but anime.
- Yeah.
- I have noticed that, I think,
the episodes that we talk about anime,
I think, perform worse than the ones
we talk about normal stuff.
- [Joey] Yeah, they do.
So people don't like it.
- But it's weird because
the clips perform better.
- Yes.
- So I mean.
- I don't let the fucking viewers
decide what we talk about.
- I talk about what I
wanna talk about, you know,
and it's weird that,
- Yeah.
it's weird that, I mean,
it's not weird because people will want,
people want us, I'm sure,
to talk about certain shows
and certain series.
'Cause that's just gonna perform better
in a short lifespan, but as a whole,
yeah, people just wanna hear us talk shit
and a chat about what's
been happening in our lives,
which right now has been not so much.
- This man's moving.
- Yeah.
I've been moving and
it's almost done, okay?
It's almost done.
- Really?
- My setup's almost done.
- Its never almost done.
You think it's done, right?
- [Garnt] Okay, okay.
You think it's done,
and then there's something
else that pops up.
- All right, all right.
How did you guys decide how
you wanna decorate your rooms?
- Okay, you know what the hardest--
- I'm gonna sound like a
fucking robot right now,
but I'm just like, I look
at a blank canvas, right?
I know I'm meant to show my personality
and I'm just like, what do I show?
How do I show personality?
- Well okay, so--
- Give me a blank space,
I have no idea what to do.
- Here's what I did, right?
In my head, all right, I've
got all these Jo-Jo posters,
that's a must, that's going
somewhere on the wall.
I've got these big ass walls, all right?
So then I know that's going there.
So then, I kind of have to
figure out what goes in between
the posters or what
goes around the posters.
And then it kind of
starts to kind of form,
and then I'm like, "Okay,
here's what I want.
I want soundproofing, I want carpet,
I want soundproof squares."
So I have an idea of stuff I want.
- And then it's kind
of putting it together
and then thinking, "Okay,
how would it look like that?"
If you know my old room, it was like,
"I want this thing on the wall, that's it.
I want posters of this, this,
that, and I don't care."
- So for me, the problem is that,
my room and the rest of my house
is designed by two different people.
My room is--
- But your room still looks good.
- Yeah, my room is good,
but like the way we,
the way myself and Aki
think about interior design
is completely like on the
opposite ends of the spectrum.
- Question, would you
decorate your bedroom,
if you lived alone?
- Yeah.
- Really?
What would you decorate it with?
- No.
- I don't know.
- I've never decorated my bedroom--
- No, I've never decorated.
- Which is why it's so fucking
difficult for me, right?
Because the way I approach interior--
- Wait, are you gonna
decorate your bedroom?
- Oh, yeah.
No, oh no, my office, sorry.
- Oh, so yeah,
- I go yeah, yeah, but I mean,
it's the same kind of deal
where my approach to interior design
is my, same approach I have
with, like, engineering.
It's all about practicality,
and that's just not good
for interior design.
I'm just like, I know,
'cause here's the thing,
here's my biggest problem
with trying to fill up my room
right now, my office is,
I know what looks bad,
but I don't know how to make it look good.
(Connor laughing)
- See, because like,
if you're an engineer,
when it comes to interior design,
I'm like a programmer, where it's like,
"If white wall equals true,
fill white wall with something."
It's like, that's it.
It's like, there's no,
like, opinion of like,
"Oh, maybe I should put something here."
It's like, no, if there's
a space on my wall,
I'm gonna find something to fill it up.
- Yeah, one thing that's
good about living in Japan
is that Japan is extremely
focused on practicality
of like, everything in your house.
Everything has to be practical.
So I kinda took a lot of that in mind
when I made my office,
I'm gonna make an office tour video,
at some point, on my main channel,
where I just go through everything
that I did in the office,
'cause I think it's
really, I think I did...
I'm pretty happy in my office.
It took me, goddamn, forever though.
- So so, easy views.
- That's the way it is.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But also I wanna talk about it
because it took me goddamn forever,
so I wanna get some value out of it.
Took me two fucking weeks,
just to soundproof the fucking room.
But I think it's really easy
to decorate a room in Japan,
when you can think more on,
like, practical sides of things.
Like, you're like,
"Okay, I want this here.
Like, I want all my anime figures."
- [Garnt] Yeah, but I
don't want them in just,
like, a cabinet, like a glass
one, because I wanna be able
to move it so I can access
the cupboards behind it,
but I don't want it on the
wall with all the posters,
see them blocked up,
so it's kind of like, "All right, so..."
There's like 10,000 things
you got to consider,
but you're just trying
to like compute them all,
but then at some point you
just gotta do something
and then see how it looks.
- [Garnt] 'Cause--
- And hope you didn't
waste your time and money.
- Yeah, because that's like,
as I've just established,
I hate wasting time,
and I'm just like, I just want
something that looks good.
I just don't know how to make it look good
without just trying it out.
What if I like rearrange all my furniture
after I've just spent
all this time building it
and like, you know, doing my best setup
and then it just looks shit.
What if it just looks shit?
Because like, I have a
bunch of like anime merch
and like, I just don't know
how to make it look good.
Like, I've tried putting my anime figures
on like a shelf or something
and I don't know why,
I just don't think, having
a bunch of anime figures
on the shelf looks good for my aesthetic.
I say this, I said, it was all this shit,
but I think it works for us, that's it.
I dunno if we came to this by
luck or if it just, you know.
- Okay, so the way Aki does it,
which I think is kind of genius,
is that what she does is,
when we first moved in, right?
I was like, "I'm gonna do my room,
you do the rest of the house."
'Cause you clearly have a
better sense of it than I do.
So what she does is she took
photos of the empty room
and then she would go into Photoshop
and literally just Photoshop
in different things
that she was thinking to buy,
to like, move it around and if--
- But I don't have
(indistinct), holy shit.
- And if it looks good, then she buys it
and puts it exactly where
she envisioned it to be.
And because then you know.
- Yeah.
- What it looks like before you bought it.
I mean, it's kinda big brain.
- Buy what you need, measure it.
- Yeah.
- Well, one thing I've, like, noticed
around anime merch now,
now that I'm like trying to
make my room actually look cool.
So a lot of anime merch
just looks really tacky.
- Yeah.
- And I didn't like,
I didn't realize this until
now that I've moved to Japan
and we've got like some cooler
things, but like I was like,
maybe I'll try putting
some wall scrolls up
and now like--
- One star.
- Even wall scrolls, just look like--
- I've graduated from wall scrolls.
- Yes, hello, I have been
to an anime convention
that is the look, when you
put up wall scrolls now.
- I've never understood
the appeal of wall scrolls.
I'll be honest.
- [Joey] Me neither.
- They look shit.
- [Garnt] I mean, I did.
- There are like, you know, like, posters.
You can get them framed.
- [Joey] Yeah.
Then they look so clean.
So like, symmetrical
as well, so beautiful.
And then the nice glass panel or plastic,
whatever the fuck it is.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
And then you've got this like
poorly printed piece of paper
with two plastic scrolls
at the top and the bottom.
- And its never like fucking,
the string just looks so tacky.
- The string looks really tacky.
- We're just calling out
everyone who has fucking
wall scrolls right now,
which is so many people.
- I feel I went through that phase though,
so I understand.
I went through the wall
scroll and poster phase
and I'm like, "I liked it at the time."
But then when I learned
about like, framed stuff,
that's when I was like, "Oh."
- But here's the thing, right?
Those JoJo posters that I have,
they're $13 per poster,
obviously it's in Japan, right?
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then the frame is like 12 bucks.
That's like 25 bucks for
a clean ass, massive,
like really high quality.
- That's cheaper than a lot of
- Wall scrolls.
- Yeah, yeah.
(crosstalk)
- Like sometimes 30 to a box.
We're talking like even the A4 ones.
Sometimes they're 20 bucks, fuck that.
I won't pay on that,
and they're always like, they
always don't look as good.
Like, the print is never as clean.
Like, I don't know, man,
I just, I don't see a--
- Yeah, I'm past the wall
scroll phase as well,
which is why, I had wall
scrolls in my old office
and I'm just like, this just looks tacky,
but I don't know how to,
I don't know what I wanna replace it with.
- Wall scrolls.
- And now,
I'm going for that problem,
where I have to figure out
what I wanna replace it with.
Well, I have like,
it's so, it's just so--
- You live in Japan.
You can get these.
- Because like--
- B4 prints.
- I think I've done like one
cool thing with my office.
Because I have like a
few cool anime merch,
and I'm just like,
"What if I just put this
all in a glass case?"
And I bought like a glass case,
which is like a four-component glass case,
and I, you know,
I filled up, like, the top
one was the junji ito bag
that I got.
The second one was like
all the anime watches
that I've got as well.
Third case was all the wine,
all the wine equipment or
the anime wine equipment
that me and Sydney have collected.
And the fourth case is going to be
for the Slam Dunk Air Jordans
that I found on Yahoo auction.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I put it up and I'm just like,
"Damn, this looks awesome."
- Yeah.
- And then I realized
that's like one 100th
of the entire fucking room.
(Joey laughing)
Fuck!
(Garnt laughing)
- That means you've got to
start collecting more stuff.
- And I'm just like, oh, it looks cool.
But like, it's like compared...
Like, putting it next to everything else,
it just looks so empty now.
- Damn, that one 10th
of my room looks epic.
- I know, right?
(Garnt laughing)
- The people, when they
rob your house, man,
they're going right for that cabinet.
The entire Garnt Maneetapho wealth
is stored in one glass full cabinet.
- Like you've been collecting JoJo figures
or JoJo fucking merch.
I'm just like, this is
how my collection starts.
It starts with one cabinet.
- Yeah.
- My God.
- Nah, I bought one of those.
I didn't buy a glass cabinet
'cause I wanted to be able to move it
'cause it's blocking my cupboards,
so I bought one on wheels
that I can just kinda
like shove out the way.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Well, one thing I
definitely underestimated
was how heavy glass is.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah, extremely so.
- Yeah.
- Why?
(Joey laughing)
Why?
What made you?
- Oh, yeah.
- No, no, well I mean.
- That looks light.
- I felt like there was
another point coming down.
I was...
(Connor laughing)
- You literally just
went, "Glass is heavy."
- [Connor] Yeah, I was waiting.
I was like, okay.
Why did you learn this?
What made you realize this?
- Okay, because...
- Garnt goes glass heavy.
- Because...
- That's all.
(Joey laughing)
- I don't know.
My point was that glass
was heavy and I did not,
like, did not--
(Connor laughing)
- What, you didn't think it was heavy?
I didn't.
- It's fucking glass.
- I didn't think about this, okay?
I don't think about this shit.
- Wait, I think everyone
knows glass is heavy,
because--
- Water is wet.
(Joey laughing)
- Because like one big issue I've had
with living in a house now,
is that you have to carry things upstairs.
And luckily enough,
my office is on the ground floor
because I had the choice between
mine being on the ground floor
and mine being on the top floor.
And I'm just like, "I want
a glass case," obviously.
And I'm just like,
once I got the glass case delivered,
I was just like, "Was
glass always this heavy?"
(Joey laughing)
- Yes, yes.
- 'Cause I don't know how
I was meant to carry this
upstairs, if I needed to,
but thank God I didn't.
- Damn, glass in Japan
is really fucking heavy.
- Yeah.
So that was my story, Garnt
discovers that glass is heavy.
- Garnt discovers that glass is heavy.
(Connor laughing)
- Hey man, I saw, picked up
a look at this metal thing.
And I was like, "Shit,
metal's kinda heavy."
- Wow.
- Damn.
Damn, okay, fine.
- Yeah, that was one thing definitely,
when I was designing my
office, where I realized,
I thought I had a lot of stuff,
but then, I realized that a lot of it
was stuff that was on my wall,
that was things like
posters and wall scrolls,
that I was like, "You know what?
Maybe it's time to change it up."
So then I got really picky
with what I would put on the walls, right?
So now I go like, you know,
my junji ito bag or what the fuck,
your skateboards, you know,
my YouTube play button
and stuff like that, you know
stuff that is more limited
and like extravagant looking.
- Yeah.
And then I realized, oh,
I actually don't have a lot of stuff
that is actually of value.
- [Connor] Right, right.
- And then I went on this like crack binge
of buying expensive shit.
Now, I have the reverse problem
where I have too much stuff now.
So I have to...
- Your room is just like
the weeb haven, you know.
- My room is, I have somehow,
I don't know when it happened,
but I've turned into, like,
a snobby art collector
when it comes to like weeb shit--
- I think I'm going through that stage
where I'm like,
- I haven't got there
yet, I'm just like, Jojo.
Just give JoJo stuff.
- Like every time I go
into an exhibit now,
I'm just like, "so where are
the expensive paintings?"
(Garnt laughing)
Fuck the mugs or the posters.
- What anime does to you man?
Fuck the T-shirts, fuck the mugs.
- I don't want your
fucking figures anymore.
- Yeah.
- I don't want the posters,
I don't want the fucking wall scrolls.
- Yeah, no, I don't want any shit.
Where are the paintings?
- Give me the cool shit.
Yeah, where's the limited shit?
- Exactly, right?
(Garnt laughing)
What can I frame?
(Joey laughing)
What can I display in the glass box?
- We got to do the anime
figure special, at some point,
you guys are saying this
shit, what the fuck?
I love figures still,
JoJo (indistinct).
- I'll walk into like a figurine shop
and I'll be like,
"So were there more than
a hundred of these made?"
I don't want it.
- Wow.
- You gonna love this shit.
- You privilege is showing, Joey.
- Does this come with a
certificate of authenticity?
- Oh, my God.
The wealth has gone to this man's head.
- But the thing about figures is that
you just need a fuck ton of
it, before it looks any good.
Otherwise it just looks
a little bit tacky,
because it's too small
to be a centerpiece,
but it needs to occupy, like, some space,
Right?
- Yeah.
And it just looks, I don't know,
unless you have like a
really, really massive figure,
to me, it doesn't like, it's--
- But even then like, a
really, really big figure
can still look a little tacky
depending on where it is.
That's where I was like,
'cause, I have that like
massive, bezerk figure.
- Oh, yeah, you do.
- And I'm still to this day,
trying to figure out where to put it.
Because it's like, everywhere,
I've like, envisioned it,
putting it in my room,
it just doesn't look
right, for some reason.
And I realize it might be
because I need to have it
next to a bunch of other figures.
- Yeah.
- But the problem is,
my biggest shelf is like,
tucked away in a corner.
So I can't, put it in.
- Yeah.
So I'm like, well fuck.
I have to like, put this,
like, shit in the living room
or something like...
- Coffee table,
- Coffee table.
- Yeah, just take the whole coffee table.
(Joey laughing)
- Isn't this like that
fucking, what's that word
that's used to describe
how the energy of a room is dictated by--
- Feng Shui.
- Yeah.
- I'm trying to figure out the Feng Shui
of my giant Beserk.
- As a kid, I'm just
like, "This is stupid."
That they're like,
you can just put things
and it doesn't matter.
Now I've realized,
"Well, my mood is affected
by how my room looks."
I'm just like, why is...
- I wouldn't go that
far personally, for me,
I'm like,
(Connor mumbling)
- Feng Shui, though it does
get pretty ridiculous at times.
- Yeah, yeah.
It's like you'll get bad luck if the--
- Some of that is
ridiculous, but I don't know,
even like my bedroom,
'cause like, I sleep better now,
because our bedroom is
orientated differently
from my old bedroom.
And I just realize, oh,
it's just 'cause of where it is
in relation to where the
window is and I'm just like,
(Garnt chuckling)
- Where was it before?
- Huh?
- Was it not near a window last time?
- No, it wasn't.
It was like on the opposite
side of the window.
(Joey snickering)
- [Joey] That probably
wouldn't have helped.
- Generally, I think,
seeing light outside is,
make your brain happier.
- [Joey] Yeah.
Normally, brain like that.
- Yeah.
- For me like, 'cause back
then, I was just like,
"Where can the bed take up
the most efficient amount of space?"
Right in that corner,
right away from the window.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Garnt] I'm just like--
- Well, If you have room
to put it in the middle,
you put it in the middle, right?
But then that's like,
that's like a big brain
saying, like, "I have space."
- Yeah, yeah, that's a flex.
- I don't know, these
other sides of the beds.
I don't even need them.
Nothing needs to go there.
I'm gonna put the bed in the middle.
- Yeah.
- I know, it's weird.
This is the first time I've actually like,
try to, think about this,
rather than just like, going--
- Man discovers interior design.
- Yeah, man discovers interior design.
- For me it was like, "Oh man,
I got more space on my wall,
guess I'll buy more JoJo prints.
- Yeah, right?
- I'll buy double.
So now I have double the
JoJo prints on my walls.
(Joey laughing)
But I've got a nice,
really cool wall of JoJos,
it's really nice.
- What have you done with,
like, the rest of your merch
that you built up, at your place?
- Oh, this is JoJo?
- Yeah.
- It's all on one like four-shelf rack.
- All right.
- Managed to place it,
and then I put like the
anti-earthquake things
in the figures that fall over.
- [Garnt] Oh.
- So yeah.
I managed to somehow get it all in,
but then I've got a bunch of
other stuff in other cupboards
that I can't like, display.
Like, I have like, a
really big, wooden, oak box
filled with the Jojo ties,
- [Garnt] Oh, right, right.
- Separate and like neat and presentable.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But there's nowhere to put it.
'Cause like,
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I don't know.
I can't just put it on the floor.
It's the Jojo ties,
this can't go on the floor, you're insane?
- Lose its value.
- Exactly, I own 14 or
15 something JoJo ties.
- Literally, every JoJo
tie that's ever been made.
- I actually don't, there's like 24.
- Oh really?
- And I have all of the
ones from part four,
which is 12 ties in total.
- Holy shit.
- I think it's 12.
So there's 12 ties from part four,
and I think there's like eight
or something from part five.
- I didn't buy all of them from part five.
- You know like when are your kid,
when you'd see that documentary
about that guy or girl,
who would collect like
Barbie dolls and Ken dolls?
(Joey laughing)
You've become that, but
just with Jojo, man.
- I have not, don't you dare.
No, 'cause they--
- Fast forward to like Connor in 50 years.
- They would go around,
they would dress up like Ken
and be like, "I'm Ken."
And they'd be like, "Please call me Ken."
- You literally, you carry where you go,
you have a fucking JoJo suit.
- You wear a JoJo suit.
- Oh, come on, that's, dude.
- It's like the only
piece of dress you own.
- This is the meme where it's
like, we are not the same.
You wear a Ken outfit, I wear a Jojo suit.
We're not the same.
Garnt wipes his ass,
I pressure wash my ass, we
are not the same, Garnt.
Don't compare, right?
Don't compare me to those
fucking people who cosplay.
We are not the same.
I wear drip, they wear
outfits, it's not the same.
- Wearing one suits, everywhere you go,
does not count as drip.
Everyone looks good in suits.
- Five suits Garnt, five--
- Everyone looks good in a fucking suit.
- Everyone looks good in a suit.
- Not, no, they don't, no they don't, bro.
No, they don't.
- You'd have to be something
like really, really bad
to fuck up looking good in the suit.
- Yeah.
- You could, you could do it.
(Garnt chuckling)
- Do it.
- How?
- Let me think about that.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Look bad in general, I guess.
- Just be really ugly.
- Just get a bad-fitting suit,
but if--
- Yeah, you know, you get
one too long, too short.
- Wear your dad's suit,
that's pretty much--
- Yeah, yeah, wear your dad's suit.
- But if it's fitted then
everyone looks good, yeah.
- I guess.
(Joey laughing)
Gee, I don't wanna concede
this point, 'cause--
- Right?
- 'Cause then I'm admitting
its the power of the suits.
- I am sticking by this point,
'cause I can't remember, someone did like,
an Anituber drip tier list or something.
- Oh, yeah.
- I can't remember who it was.
I remember you were like...
- I think, Mudan did one, right?
- I don't think it was Mudan,
'cause whoever this person--
- Oh, the first one.
- Yeah, the first one,
whoever this person was like,
put Connor in like S-tier.
And I'm just like,
Connor does not deserve to
go in fucking S-tier drip,
he just wears one fucking Jojo suit,
and calls it a day.
- Everyone is blinded by the
Jojo suit, that is not drip.
- And I just say, it should be,
it's a good suit, it looks--
- If everyone had a Jojo suit,
everyone would be in S-tier.
- Well then everyone should
get a JoJo suit, Joey.
- That's not drip.
- Just you wait.
- I want to start a charity service
to give everyone a JoJo suit
to move you down the drip tier.
(Joey laughing)
That's how much I care about this shit.
- And yeah, I saw that, I saw that--
- I'm gonna come back in a
few weeks with more drip.
- I saw that TLS video,
and when they put Connor on
S-Tier because of the JoJo suit,
I'm like, this man
literally is in a S-tier
while wearing an Emia like shirt.
I'm like, how the fuck?
- You're gonna say, you're gonna tell me
the same fucking Emia shirts that he wears
on like every other week of Trash Taste
puts him in S-tier on drip.
- That is...
- I'm leaving.
- That is--
- I'm like, I got fucking
B-tier compared to this pawn,
compared to this person.
- Boy, you are B-tier drip,
man, get off my S-tier.
- No, no, what's worse is that
I was also S-tier but
I worked for my shit.
I actually have like a
wardrobe full of shit
and I get beaten by one JoJo suit,
which I also have.
- Yeah, which we all fucking heard.
- You should get five
then, shouldn't you Garnt?
And then we'll talk.
You have one JoJo suit, I have five,
we are not the same, Garnt.
- The weeb standard of drip is so low
that's what I wanted to add.
- It's 'cause--
- I'm not normally salty
but that day I was salty.
- That was the day, when I
was like, "What this fuck?"
- This is my confirmation
that weebs do not have drip.
- Yeah.
- Every time I post
pictures in the Jojo suit,
the perfect suit factory,
the maker of the suit,
posts it to their Instagram.
- Do they actually?
- Yeah.
I couldn't believe it.
At least twice they've done it,
and I was like, "Oh, okay, cheers."
They're like, "Look, this is drip."
- See, the makers of the suit agree.
I should be, I am drip.
- I don't think they post--
- They made the suit.
- I don't think they re-posting it
because they think it's drip,
I think they're re-posting it
because they fucking made it.
- No, no, no,
they're re-posting 'cause
they're like, "Shit, man."
- They're like this post got viral.
- No, no.
- We buy wierd Daiso socks
and put it up on an Instagram post.
I'm sure Daiso would re-tweet it.
And they won't say, "This is drip."
They'll say thank you for buying
our fucking 100 Yen socks.
- All right, let's watch
it happen then, Joey.
- All right.
Well, no, I'm not going to go--
- Why not?
No, no.
- I don't wear Daiso socks.
- You all wish, I'll buy you a pair.
- Fuck Daiso socks, its
all about the Family Mart.
- It's all about the fucking Family Mart.
- Are you wearing it now?
- It's all about the Family Mart socks.
- Have we ever talked about this before?
- No.
- [Joey] I don't know.
So Joey and Garnt came to me
one day and they were like,
"Have you worn Family Mart socks before?"
Family Mart socks, which
is a convenience store,
obviously, in Japan.
- [Joey] Yeah.
I was like, "No, why would
I wear Family Mart socks?"
- 'Cause they were amazing.
- And then they were like,
"They're the most
comfortable socks on earth".
And I was like, "All right, okay."
- So one of my gaijin friends living here,
like, told me about this,
like, revelation being
like, "Have you heard?"
He came to me like fucking
Jehovah's Witnesses,
like, "Have you heard of
the Family Mart socks?"
I was like, "No, please do tell" .
And they're like, I
think, like the 400 yens,
it was like three, four
bucks, for a pair of socks.
And I was like, "How good
could a $4 pair of socks be
at a convenience store of all places?"
Wore it, felt like I was floating, bro.
Literally, and then I was like,
I have to tell, it was
like, I am totally into it.
- Yeah, yeah, you got turned into a, like,
a Jehovah's witness.
- Yeah, I was converted.
- He starts preaching to me about this.
I was around his house, right?
I was around his house,
I would play Mahjong, and
he starts preaching to me.
I'm just like, it's just
fucking socks, Joey.
Aki comes back with
like five pairs of socks
then he goes, "Yeah, I'll
give you one for free."
I'm like, "I don't need
this, it's a pair of socks."
- It's literally the
guy giving the Bibles,
just give it a go.
What am I gonna do with this?
And I remember I got home and
put it on when the corner.
And I remember we had a Trash
Taste recording the other day,
and I hadn't done my
washing the day before,
I opened my drawer,
empty sock drawer, except
for the one Family Mart sock,
and he always, he was just,
he was just staring me in
the face and I'm just like,
"Oh fine, I'll wear
the Family Mart socks."
And like, there's this one
scene from "Rick and Morty"
where Rick gives Morty like
the perfectly flats piece
of land, right?
Do you remember that scene?
- I think so.
I can't remember where.
- Where it's like perfectly
flat and Morty's like,
"Oh, what is this?"
Oh, it's just perfectly funny."
He steps on it, and he
literally starts coming.
And I was like, "Oh, it's
just fucking so, so good,
how good could this be?"
And I put it on and I'm just
like, "Oh, it fits so snugly.
It's hugging my feet.
What is this feeling?
What is this, cotton?
It's so soft."
It's like I'm walking on ship right now.
What is this?"
And I answer, and I text Joey,
I'm just like, "Fuck you."
But I was like, I have
done, I have converted it.
I don't know why it feels so smooth
and so silky smooth on your skin.
- I can't wear any of those socks.
- It feels like a thousand
kisses on your feet.
- My favorite pair of socks,
I bought two years ago,
it's from Lawson's.
Telling you, they do a black pair
of socks and they are like
the cleanest socks I own.
- Are they as good as
the Family Mart socks?
- I think they're better.
I bought these socks, for two years,
I've been washing them.
- We have the Family
Mart gospel right now.
- They have not lost their
like, their firmness,
they haven't worn out at all.
You know, as soon as you
get socks to go crinkly
and they go hard after a
while when you wash them
because they've been used so much,
these socks, fucking warriors, bro.
They're like day one,
they look no different.
These socks are amazing.
- (indistinct) mad brother,
but he's just lost his way.
He's lost his way, we will guide
you to the right direction.
You guys give me a pair of Family Mart,
I'll give you guys pair of
the Lawson's blacks I have,
you'll see.
- Trash Taste sock rating.
- You'll see, these socks are impeccable.
- It's so insane because
I remember walking
into a Family Mart in Tokyo the other day,
and they literally had a table just
for the Family Mart socks by themselves,
which just shows how far
the gospel was spread.
They've literally got a table, front
and center in the combination.
(indistinct)
- Yeah, that's because they're
probably always sold out.
Like every, I think
I've been to about four
or five different Family
Marts, after I'd try the socks,
and I was like, "I have to get more."
So I was like scouting around Tokyo.
I swear, for the first
four or five Family Marts,
they were all sold out.
- I'm curious, what made you
buy them in the first place?
- It's just like a thing that started
with like, guidance living in Japan.
Like one, yeah, one of the
foreign is those leaving key,
like, posted on Twitter about like,
trying out these Family Mart socks,
and then it kind of just
spread like wildfire from it.
And then it made its way to me.
- [Man Off Camera] Yeah,
it's the Family Mart socks
and the pumpkin spice latte combo.
- Yeah, that's right.
- And what was pumpkin spice latte got
to do with these?
- [Man Off Camera] Starbucks,
it's a Gaijin thing.
- Oh, because pumpkin
spice lattes in the spot.
- Spice latte has only just
now become really massive
in Japan because of the (indistinct).
And I guess the same thing happened
with the Family Mart socks,
and so everyone was like, "All right,
let me tell you full
bucks, I'll try it out."
And then the gospel spread.
And I'm like, "This is, I'm pretty sure
this is how religion stuff (laughs).
- Through (indistinct).
- Says it's good, and
then the rest follow.
- One sock at a time, religion spread.
- This episode is sponsored by Honey.
- You know how these podcasts ads to go,
we read a spiel, blah, blah, blah, blah,
that's in the script as well, by the way.
- And then we give you a
promo code or a discount,
and then that's the end of it.
- But this time it is
different (indistinct).
- Because this is an ad for Honey.
And our Honey ad doesn't just give you
one promo code, a Honey
ad gives you millions
of promo codes.
That's right, millions of
promo codes in one address.
- All right, so when you shop,
Honey will automatically
fill in the promo code box
for you to check out,
but it won't just fill
it in with one code,
it'll dump a ton of codes in there.
My God, every code it can fit.
- I know you know zero codes, Joey.
- It knows more than zero codes.
- Oh my God.
- Then it tests them in seconds to see
if one gives you a discount,
and plus, Honey knows what
to look for promo codes
that are hard to find on your own.
- I was buying your Christmas
presents, spoiler alert.
I might've used Honey to get
myself a bit of a discount.
- You cheap shit.
- So get all the promo
codes Honey can find
at joinhoney.com/trashtaste,
that's joinhoney.com/trashtaste,
link's in the description below.
Back to the episode.
Fuck you, Garnt (indistinct).
- Back to the episode.
- Going back on the topic
of watching stuff though.
So as I have been watching anime again,
I wanted to know if you have
had the same experience,
where do the subtitles
actively distract you now
from like, what's going on?
- In English?
- Yeah, if you have English subtitles on.
- Sometimes, I can turn
off the part of my brain
that's trying to listen to the Japanese.
I can just ignore that.
- 'Cause like, I, because like I,
this was the first time
I started watching anime
for my video, and of
course, I turn on subtitles
because I had to understand
what was going on,
'cause I've been watching anime as
for like a long period of
time without subtitles,
and it was so weird turning it back on
because it like actively,
I actually dislike it now,
it actively distracts me
from what's going on--
- (indistinct) any anime
with subtitles now.
- I'm trying not to.
- You have become next level (indistinct).
- I'm like, trying to watch as much anime
without subtitle subtitles on.
I was like, because like,
what I've realized is that it actually,
it actively hurts your
language learning process
if you have English subtitles on well,
or at least here's the way--
(indistinct)
- Here's the way I see it, right?
'Cause say you have like
a Japanese sentence,
or hear a Japanese sentence
and you want the English
translation of that.
If the translator for the
subtitle is doing their job,
they would have translated
what they're saying
into natural English, so
that it sounds natural.
Whereas when I'm trying to learn Japanese
and I'm trying to process
the Japanese in my head,
what I've read in the subtitles,
and what's being said are
like all the same things,
but it's different.
Like I would actually,
like, I realized this where I
think it would be more useful
for me if I had Google
translated subtitles
than an actual, like
professionally translated subtitle.
Because when I'm going back
and I'm trying to understand
something and I read the
official translation,
I'm just like, "Well, yeah,
that," and I, you know,
I do my work to translate it.
I'm like, "Yeah, that's what's being said,
but that's not how I think
about that sentence being heard
in my brain.
- But that's also like the problem, right?
Is that I think at the end of the day,
like, so much of it is nuanced
because grammatically
it's just so different.
A lot of it is just completely,
I've read some subtitles where
it's just being completely
lost in translation because
there are just some things.
So some phrases and ways
of saying a sentence
and the way of describing something
that is so specifically Japanese,
that if the translator
tries to translate it
without the translator notes,
you have to explain it,
then it just becomes like,
it becomes so nuance to the
point that it almost becomes
like a subjective
translation where it's like,
I personally think this is
what they're trying to say,
but it's not true.
A hundred percent the same.
And I feel that if people
try and use that as a way
to learn grammar, then they're
going to get one nuanced way
of learning it, which
is not exactly accurate.
- Yeah, when I was
watching the American films
I've seen in Japan, they
have the Japanese subtitles
and it's really interesting.
- [Joey] Yeah, it is.
- I'm like, that would be
like, a really heavy amount of slang,
and I'll just translate it
into something extremely simple
and mundane, but it doesn't really convey
the situation (indistinct).
But obviously, it works
all the way around as well.
But like, I watch, actually,
you know it's quite helpful
watching Japanese TV,
because they have subtitles in Japanese
on the screen every goddamn two seconds,
rip editors, but yeah,
they have the subtitles on
screen and I find it way easier
to watch Japanese stuff
with Japanese subtitles.
Because I know, I know
a fair amount of Kanji,
like basic stuff, so I
can normally kind of,
it really helps me solidify the sentence.
Because often I just, I'm just intaking
and I don't see anything
to kind of like lay it out.
And when I'm hearing stuff
and I can see the line,
I can kind of be like, "Oh,
that's what he's saying."
Because there's some words
that can mean like, you know,
like, you wanna say
tata, like source tata,
but then like tata can mean
like so many different things
in so many different contexts.
If when there could be like advice, right?
It could be like a recommendation of like,
oh, you should do this right.
So it's really confusing because sometimes
if you stop paying
attention for one second
and then you hear something like tata,
and then you're panicking,
figuring out what way
they're using this word,
that could mean so many things.
And so it's really confusing,
but then having the subtitles in Japanese,
oh, okay, well, I just saw the first part,
like, glanced at the second part, like,
I can figure out what's going on.
- I think every language
is like that though.
Even in English, where it's
like the word of, for instance,
it can mean a million
different things depending
on the sentence.
And Japanese, I think is just
like a little more difficult
because you know it again,
like unlike in English,
where there is spaces between words
that clearly distinguished
between what this word means,
versus what this next word means,
in Japanese, we don't have that.
It's just one continuous flow.
- I remember the first
time I saw like, you know,
I opened like a Japanese light novel
or something and I'm just like,
"This fucking terrifies me."
(laughing)
It's just one continuous line of text,
I'm just like, "What's--"
- The only thing that stops
it is a comma or a period.
And then everything else
is still so nonstop.
- I've never thought I
could get terrified by it,
like, just letters before,
until I opened like a
Japanese novel, I'm just like,
"This is just one line,
where's the separation?"
Come on guys."
- I feel like this is
a very small nitpick.
You know how?
Because obviously in Japanese, right?
The subject comes first.
So more often than not when
they're like explaining
like plot twists in anime,
it's so hard to like hype it up
because the subject comes first,
so it's like, gone, the
killer or something.
And the killer was
gone, it's always like--
- Actually, in Japanese, we can do that.
Yeah, we can do that way.
Like, you know, for example, like,
Moda mystery stories in
Japanese do this a lot.
Like, you know, normally
if someone were to say like
you're the culprit, in English,
we can do the same thing,
you can say the culprit is you,
or you're the culprit, right?
Like, the same thing in Japanese,
if I were to say "You're
the culprit," in that order,
that'd be (speaks in Japanese)
versus (speaks in Japanese).
You're the culprit.
- Which one sounds more natural though?
Because like--
- They're both natural.
- Okay, because what I noticed
about English is that--
- It's just source of Japanese.
- No, but what I've
noticed is that, you know,
with the translation, it,
with translating the Japanese,
like natural English or some
English that reads naturally,
like, sometimes you can get
the same meaning across in English,
it just sounds really Jahnke.
And especially with how
the sentence structure,
and the Japanese grammar is.
- Sounds like languages are
like nothing alike, fudge.
- Not every language is like English.
- As like learning the second,
because like, obviously,
we've all had second languages
that we've never really learned
as learning like a third language
for you made you appreciate
(indistinct) more.
- A hundred percent.
Straight up, no, not really
like, yeah, for sure.
I took it for granted,
but then again, like,
I also feel like God, I've like,
I never, ever wanted to learn, in my mind,
I always have the mindset
of like, you know,
I know this is very close
minded, but I was just like,
I'm just gonna not speak English,
I already hate the language,
I thought that way.
And I still, to this day,
I hate learning languages.
Yeah, I'm fucking tryna learn a third.
What's up with that?
What's up with that, man?
- I wanna learn a third language,
I just don't really
have the time right now.
- The problem is that you
won't like, (indistinct)
unless you're like one of those
people who's just obsessed
with languages and learning them.
Like, I feel like you will
only learn the other language
if you need to, which is the
only reason why I'm doing it.
Like, I'm finally at a point
where I know people like online,
there was one, there are
high Japanese and stuff,
and it's so hard to convey
how your Japanese is
when you don't need to speak it.
I don't wanna speak it online sometimes
'cause it's embarrassing.
Like, Chris will always try
and get my fucking Japanese.
I know why Chris is fucking doing it,
'cause he wants to feel
good about his Japanese.
Motherfucker, 'cause
obviously, Chris's Japanese
is better than mine, like--
- Not by much though.
(laughing)
When I see Chris, he has no problem
in conveying a lot of like, thoughts.
- When I'm with him,
he'll do anything he can
to not speak Japanese.
- It's like the same thing.
- (indistinct) I wanna
do it in front of you
because it's embarrassing.
'Cause he's gonna feel like
I've been here for eight years,
I should speak better.
And like, yeah.
Like, you know,
whatever amount you wanna
learn, you can learn.
Even though I wanna get better,
I've gotten to a point now
where I can pretty much do
everything, except for
government documents.
Everything is not problem--
- I can barely do that.
- I can go to the bank,
that's how I know my
fluency is increasing.
As somebody who came here
literally knowing nothing,
I'm pretty proud of where I've
come from, how far I've come.
But like, you know, it is,
again, it fucking sucks online.
- 'Cause people expect you to
like, reach a certain level
by a certain time.
- Sometimes I forget what?
Sometimes I forget a
word that I should know,
sometimes I forgot an easy word.
- I'm exactly the same,
where like it's I was putting in hours,
like, every single day for
like, a good, like two,
three month periods.
And then I went back to England,
and it's like going to the
gym where you build up this,
you build up this routine
and you're like, great,
"I'm doing this routine."
And then something comes along
to fuck over that routine,
and then like, it just
cascades and you miss a day
and then you miss two days
and then you miss a week and you're like,
"Fuck, now I'm starting
to forget (indistinct).
Like, that's where I'm at now
where like, I was making
such good progress,
and then I went to New England,
and then it just cascaded,
and I'm like, trying to
have to put the effort
in to relearn some of the
stuff that I knew before,
and now I've just forgotten
because I wasn't putting the
active hours in every day.
- I have, speaking of gym,
I have really fucking
struggled to get back into it.
Like, it is hard.
I forgot how hard it was
to get back into the gym
if you fall out because you know,
when you're going every week,
you don't really get
sore the next day much.
It doesn't really happen
because you're pretty
eating the right thing,
your body's used to you doing it,
and like, I rarely got like very sore.
Now when I go, I'm sore
for like four days,
because I haven't gone a month.
So you combine that with like,
also having a busy schedule,
and I wanna go more,
but you need to go at least once a week
or more to kind of build it up, right?
But now if I'm sore for four days,
I'm not gonna go for these four days.
And I gotta pray that
my schedule isn't full
on the other two days that
I'm able, and I want to go.
But of course, life isn't like that,
and most of the time, I'm doing something,
I've got to go somewhere for shoots,
so it's like, fuck man, I'm really trying
to get back into this,
but it is so goddamn hard to get back
into the gym as an adult
when you fall out of it,
it is so difficult, because
most people just aren't used
to making a lot of time for it.
And it's something that I
will not empty my schedule
to go to the gym.
To me, it's like, I
know I should exercise,
I enjoy it.
I really love going, but I
wanna do everything else first,
I wanna prioritize my work first,
and then I'll go to the gym.
- I mean, it's just being an adult.
- Have you signed up to a gym?
- I have them not signed up to a gym.
- I mean, like--
- Are you going to?
- Probably not.
I kind of had this realization
where the little free time
that we have to work with,
I'm either gonna go to the
gym or I'm gonna use that
to learn Japanese. And I chose,
I made the active choice to be like,
I'm going to put whatever free time I have
into learning Japanese, that's my choice.
Because I'm not, like I, before
I was like, "I can do both,
I've got time to do both,"
and then what I realized
is that I didn't have time to do both,
And by trying to do both, I didn't either.
And so I knew I needed to like,
'cause the thing is, either
with gym or language learning,
I think discipline is
the most important thing.
Like, the idea is nice,
if I could go into the gym
every week or every day,
or putting an hour of whatever you want
into learning Japanese,
but it's not gonna happen
if you're not gonna like,
commit to it.
And you need to just be
like strict with yourself
to be like, "This is
going to go beyond me,"
just having this idea of I
wanting to do this thing,
and me just putting in
like the real hours to it.
- I think one thing that I, took this
from (indistinct) as well.
- Of course.
- Is what he said.
And honestly, it really resonated with me.
He said that like, he goes
to the gym a bunch, right,
obviously, because he's
an absolute human machine.
(indistinct) on this man
is literally like, insane.
He was like, and I, and to this day,
like, I still firmly believe this.
He was like, "Even if you have
the shittest day on earth,
if you go to the gym and you work out,
you've done something.
You've actively feel like
you've made some progress
on something.
And like, you know, work
doesn't have to go right,
your relationships don't have to go right,
but at least you had that
one thing that you've done
that was good for you.
And to be honest, when you go to the gym,
like, the one thing I
really loved about it,
and this is part of the
reason I go is 'cause the day,
so I like to go in the morning,
I don't really like going at night,
it's not really my thing.
When I go to the gym in the morning,
the rest of the day is like, amazing.
Like, my energy is high, I feel great,
the next, I sleep well,
I normally have a good
next day too, as well.
So I just find that
everything improves when I go,
that's why I do like going,
the fuck is it hard to do it?
- I like, this year, I opted
to get up at like, you know,
around like, eight or 9:00 AM, 9:00 AM--
- I'll be doing that as well.
- And even if I got
barely any fucking sleep
the night before, even if I
went to bed at like 3:00 AM,
I always try and get up at
least like, 9:00 AM latest,
just because I know that in
between 9:00 AM and lunch,
if I get something done before lunch,
I feel fucking amazing.
I'm like, "I got something
done, it's just lunchtime."
(indistinct)
- It's such a simple life hack where like,
waking up early--
- Wake up early.
- (indistinct) Y'all you'll feel better
if you wake up early.
As a kid, I'm like, "Shut
up, let me stay up till--"
- Fuck you.
- "Let me stay up till 5:00
AM playing video games,
see how that hurts me."
I know, who knew that it hurts you?
- It hurts you, oh, it hurts.
- But the one good thing about,
there's two sides of this coin.
So if you are waking up
at nine all the time,
even if you go to bed at like 5:00 AM,
you have like, a night out,
you'll probably still wake up at nine,
'cause your body is like,
"This is time to wake up, get up now."
And I have been, you feel shit all day,
but at least you still
maintain the sleep schedule,
you know what I mean?
But on the other side,
I remember when I used
to wake up at like one or 2:00 PM,
it's not my proudest of days.
- I think we've all been there, yeah.
- I would wake up at this time.
One good thing was that,
one, I normally just like,
didn't eat as much.
I found that when I'm awake
all day, I'm eating a lot more,
that's good or bad.
- I wonder why.
- 'Cause I'm just having more shit to do.
I would eat less, 'cause
I would just eat a meal
at like, eight and then I
would go to bed at 4:00 AM.
But the other thing is when
I go out with my friends
and we're going drinking,
I'm getting really tired by like 10.
And I'm like, "Fuck, (indistinct)."
I remember when I would
wake up at two, we went out,
I'd be like, 4:00 AM, "Are you both good?
I'm still good to go, man,
let's go to this party,
let's keep going."
And everyone's like, "Oh,
I'm so tired, I gotta go,
I got work tomorrow."
I'm like, "Let's keep
going, let's keep partying."
And then now I'm that guy who's like,
"Dude, it's like 9:00 PM,
man, I gotta get back soon."
You know, sad, man, I
can't, it's so hard for me--
- I remember when I first, like,
when we first started coming to Japan,
like, me and Joey had this
thing, where every time
I would come, we would do
like Oni karaoke, every time,
every single fucking time.
- Like, twice a week.
- Bro, we're gonna have to do
that when people come here.
- Oh my God, can we go in the morning
and just go all the way
until like 10:00 PM in this?
- I hope he's right.
Content creators who wanna
come on Trash Tastes,
your (indistinct) on Twitter.
There's a very, very small
amount of people watching this.
If you come here, please, don't all come
at the same time, I'm begging, please.
- We're gonna die.
- It's gonna happen though,
when the country opens up,
there's just gonna be a,
like a mass fucking people
just coming in the country.
- I saw people on Twitter
were like, talking,
they were like, "Any other
content creators wanna arrange
a trip to Japan with the foot,
when it opens up right away?"
And I was like, "Please, no."
- Come and smoke.
- At let's not do the all
night karaoke, 'cause like,
man, that morning, that train home
or that taxi home or that, whatever,
however the fuck you get home,
is like the most depressing
thing in the world.
- Dude, when I was coming back
from your housewarming party,
it was like, 2:00 AM on a taxi,
and I'm like, "God, I wanna die."
It was the most depressing
taxi I've been on in so long.
- There's just something about
going home after a night out,
when you can see the
sun, that is just like--
- That is like, "What am I doing?"
- I'm like, you're walking in the streets
and you're just like--
- Everyone else is going to work.
- And you're like, "Look
at all these people
with an adequate amount of
sleep in their body, fuck them."
- I feel homeless.
I feel like a homeless
man roaming the streets.
(indistinct)
- Oh my God, yeah, I remember that,
I used to go out to like 4:00
AM when I first came here.
I liked that.
- That was good times.
- Those fun times, but--
- I can still do it, I got it,
like, everyone's got to agree.
- It needs to be like, to
me, like, we used to do it
on a whim, but now I'm
like, it needs to be.
(indistinct)
- We all got to agree, we're
like, this is a hard one, boy.
We're going hard, we're
all gonna get drunk.
- I got to like go to sleep
really early the night before
so I can get like enough sleep
before my waking up at 8:00 AM.
- Oh my God.
- No, because like, for me,
I luckily, like, if I want to stay up,
I can stay up really easily,
but what that just means
is I just lose a day.
It's just, I lose a day
if I stay up late now.
It's like, my actions have consequences.
- At every part of--
- Is this motherfucker who's last alive.
He's always the one up until like seven.
- I don't get it.
- I like to, sometimes I, you know,
I don't really get much
(indistinct) anymore at parties,
I don't really feel
like I have to stay up.
Once I'm done, I'm like, "Later, guys,"
If I'm the first to go to sleep,
I'm the first to go to
sleep, no qualms about it.
It's whatever my body is
saying, I'm like, "Later, guys."
Especially if I need to
do something the next day
or they wanna hang out again the next day,
I wanna be awake to like
spend time with you guys.
(indistinct) I must stay awake.
(indistinct)
- I dunno, it's just when
people are there, I'm just like,
"I wish to converse now,
I wish to socialize."
- Okay, that I do feel
a bit if (indistinct).
If I haven't seen my
friends in ages, I'm like,
"I really want to talk to you,
but I'm so tired, so I'm gonna go to bed."
- Well that's the thing, right?
It's like, if it's just
like a regular night,
and I'm like, I could stay up
and do whatever I'm
doing until like 4:00 AM,
but then I think to myself, I'm like,
"This is shit I can just
do tomorrow morning."
So now it's like, "I
don't have to do it now."
- Yeah, I mean, it's different,
like if it's like friends
I hadn't seen in a while,
I'll fucking stay up.
- Oh yeah, that is like the
one exception where I'm like,
yeah, I'll be having be having
(indistinct) like 5:00 AM.
It was just like a normal nights out,
these lads who I see every week, I'm like,
"Guys, I'm getting a bit tired--"
- "I'm gonna see you next week."
I'm like, "I'm going to bed, fuck you."
- I need a piss quickly.
- Oh my, God--
- I'm sorry, I didn't take one last time
when we had a long break.
- This man has a woman bladder.
- Sorry to finish up your
regular Trash Taste episode,
because by the way, did you know?
We stream on Trash Taste.
Every single Tuesday at 7:00
PM, GST these times on screen,
we will be live doing some fun things.
We we'll be tasting food,
doing some challenges,
this is a spelling bee.
Why wouldn't you here live
watching it, Americans?
We know you're asleep, but
come and watch the streams.
So smash that Twitch link in
the description down below
to come watch these streams live,
and maybe you'll be on the
chat on screen somewhere,
I hope I'm pointing it right.
Look, one camera, one camera,
chase the other camera with Joey.
Now back to the middle camera.
(indistinct)
You're missing out on all this fun stuff.
Come watch Trash Taste live.
- Trash Taste is on Twitch,
twitch.tv/trashtastepodcast.
- I got this, don't worry about it.
Twitch.tv/trashtastepodcast,
7:00 PM JST every week
until the end of December.
Link's down on the description below,
come and hang out with us, see you then.
- Make sure you hit that Follow button.
- Going back to like,
languages and stuff though.
Like I did have this thought
and I don't mean to like sound
elitist or gatekeep something else, but--
(indistinct)
- Do you think you can
truly understand the culture
if you don't like, have
at least like a bit
of an understanding of the language?
Because what made me think
this was, learning Japanese
has really made me appreciate
Thai and Thai culture,
and made me think about my own language
or my second language in a way
that I never thought about before.
Because to me, learning a
language or like, learning Thai
was just the way I communicated to my mom,
and it didn't like, I didn't
internalize just how much
of my culture was steeped into
my language until I started
to try learning Japanese.
And you know, like, like we just said,
you can translate things, right?
You can translate ideas, but one thing
that I've found learning Japanese,
or like, now I appreciate
in time was like,
sometimes it's really hard to
translate a certain feeling
you get from a phrase.
- I think it's impossible
to learn a language
without learning the
culture, and vice versa.
- I think you can learn the language
without knowing anything
about the culture.
- Really?
- I don't think you can.
- I think you can.
- But I mean, what's the point?
Yeah.
- But you can't, but like, I think, yeah,
of course, you can,
'cause it's a set of rules
and you, you follow them
and you say the words like--
- Because, you know, I did, but like--
- You can teach a robot language,
doesn't have to understand
the culture behind it,
but it knows--
- That's a robot, what
I'm saying is that like,
well, if that can be done,
that shows that, I mean,
you don't need to understand the culture.
Like you don't have to
understand the culture,
but I think if you
wanna, on the other hand,
if you wanna understand
more about the culture,
now your question was
knowing the culture, right?
Like I think if you wanna
know more about the culture,
the language is probably
the best way to do it.
- I would argue that they
kind of, they go hand in hand.
Like I feel because the language
of a country is a culture.
So it's like, I feel like,
yes, you could like, you know,
as you said, you can
teach a robot Japanese.
And again, you know,
speak back in Japanese,
but that's because that's
a Royal right there.
It has the one to standing
all the actual language.
And I feel in, you can only
get so far learning a language
without knowing the culture.
- Yeah, and I'm only like
counterpoint to that.
It's like, well, on the
other hand, it's like,
English is constantly changing
as is, as are most languages.
Like you go back 80 years
and you watch Japanese,
you already don't understand
the Japanese that well.
Same thing, you know,
language is a constantly changing thing.
But language is like culture
as a whole, but in some ways,
culture is a reflection of the language
that changes over time.
- That's exactly my point, where it's been
like such a weird journey
for me learning Japanese
and just having, like,
I feel like having like a
different part of my mind unlocked
it's it's it's so it's so weird.
- To charge 1% of his brain.
- It's so weird to try to
describe this to someone who has
never tried to learn a language or has,
or only knows one language.
You kind of like, even,
you could kind of even like
think differently with a second
language or like, you know, it's a.
- People have told me,
people have told me,
I sound different when I speak Japanese.
Like I become a totally
different person, but I'm like,
I would argue that that's
because the Japanese side of me
that speaking Japanese follows
more of the Japanese cultural
way of life,
which is completely different
to the Australian way of life.
- Is there any like Japanese
concepts in language that you
think I like have combi translated
all like are difficult to
translate?
- Oh, absolutely.
Absolutely. I mean like, yeah.
I mean, you know, it's, I
don't think it's just like,
it's not just like one phrase
that can't be translated or
whatever. I mean, there's lots of,
I would argue that there's a
lot of English words that can't
be translated to joy.
That's definitely, but yeah.
Like Boston, for instance.
Right. Oh, you know,
there's a lot of Japanese woods
that take an entire sentence
to describe in English. Right.
But like, you know, there are
some like, especially like,
you know, I think the whole thing of like,
just Kanji especially is
so difficult to translate
without fully first explaining
what the Kanji even is.
And that's why I always found
it interesting that there are
so many like Japanese, like, you know,
manga anime and stuff like that,
that so heavily rely on the
Japanese language and therefore
the Japanese culture that
have somehow been translated
and have somehow still
been understood by people
who have no knowledge of
the language or the culture.
Like it still baffles my mind,
how popular the "Monogatari"
series is outside of Japan,
because that show I've seen the subtitles.
A lot of it gets lost in
translation so hard. Yeah.
But somehow people still enjoy it.
- Ideas are still there.
Maybe. I don't know.
But I feel that like, you know, it's,
it's interesting to see like
how a Japanese person would
react to a show like that
versus how a non-Japanese person
will react to a show, both
good, both positive outcome,
but a completely different
level of understanding of what
makes it good.
- Yeah, and like the language
also tells the history
of the country. Well,
you know, like, you know,
we have a lot of French words
in English from when France
had control over England,
but Japanese has tons of
English words and you know,
it also Japanese have a lot of
words that are like very cute
sounding to reflect the nature
of Japanese society right now.
It all, it all kind of reflects
it in a way that's really
interesting and kind of bizarre, really.
It doesn't really make much sense of yeah.
- 'Cause because I,
I realized when I went back
to England and I was speaking,
you know, speaking Thai
against my mum there,
they were just like some tie
concepts and tie like words
that I just didn't know
couldn't be translated into English,
into my thought about it.
There's this concept of entire called Jai
which means the heart's right,
and a lot of things, a
lot of things revolve
around this concept of Jai.
So basically lawn means hot heart.
So that means you're in patients. Right.
And that's, that's the
literal translation, right?
Gin means patients cold hearts right now.
There's this word called Lam lungi,
which means water flowing from the heart.
And you explain that to English.
Like what the does that water,
water flow from the heart disease?
And it's like it's drinkable water flowing
from the heart means it's
someone giving genuine acts
of kindness with no strings attached.
They just wanna be welcoming.
And they are willing to give
just these genuine acts of
kindness so that everyone
around them has a good time
and is more welcomed.
And they do that with no strings
attached. And like, there,
there is no English
translation for that. Like,
cause the closest thing you could say is--
- 90 words to explain it.
- Yeah, exactly, the
closest thing you can say
is like kinds, but it's
not, it's not really kind,
but like, unless you know, Tai,
I mean not unless, you know, Tai,
but like if you've been to Thailand,
you can feel this feeling, right.
This feeling that exudes from
the country, which is why,
which w which is why it's a
great place to go on holiday.
Cause everyone they're so
welcoming because a lot of people
there have non PII and like, it's,
it's so hard to explain that
into a different language
because in Thai,
that is just a concept that
you feel because it's just so
steeped in the culture and
you feel it when you go there.
But if you don't speak the language,
then you don't have a proper
word to place on this feeling
that you feel, people exuding,
same thing with Japan as well.
You feel a certain feeling
from, you know, that, you know,
someone who grew up in Japan
may have a different way of
thinking and a different way
of acting than say someone who
grew up outside of Japan. And there's,
there's so many like nuances
with just culture and just
psychology that is so like
steeped into language that it's
it's, you can explain it,
but from what I've, from,
what I've from,
what I've experienced is the
difference between explaining a
joke and understanding
a joke. You know, now,
now that I've been an avid anime
watch of my entire life and
I've had Japanese concepts
explained to me it's like been so
weird actually feeling some of
these concepts as opposed to
just understanding them. And I think.
- Yeah, like one concept I
can think of in Japanese,
it's like this idea of reading
the room or reading the--
- Oh yeah.
- So kooky for like air in Japanese.
But like, and you know, we say
like, when we read the room,
we say cook you'll you'll
know which means to read the,
read the air, but like,
it's not quite the same as
when you say reading the app or
reading the room in English,
there's like a whole other,
like, it's,
it's like a socio psychological
element that it's like,
it's so important to read the
room and not reading the room
or not reading the air in
Japanese culture is so like not
good. Like that's like, you're
basically just, you know,
societaly just, it's, it's
a societal death basically.
- It's like a communication
within Japanese society that
doesn't require.
- It's. Yeah.
It's, it's a thing that
doesn't require was,
and it's like this,
like non-spoken social
etiquette of sorts that Japanese
people have just hardwired into
the brain from a young age,
because it's just so
integrated and it's a society.
And you know, again,
that's like another concept
where you can explain it in
another language and I'm sure, you know,
if you like looked into it and
understood it, then you know,
you can be like, all right,
I get what that means.
You know, I can, I know how
to say it in this context,
but you know, even for me, it's like,
I don't think I could fully use
or utilize the word or fully
understand what that word means,
because I personally didn't
grow up as heavily in an
environment like that.
Like I grew up with it.
Sure. But I wasn't born
and raised in Japan.
So it's like, there's that
sort of disconnect of yeah.
As you said,
like understanding it from
an explanation and just
understanding it through
osmosis and like yeah. It's.
- There's a lot of
things I've never thought
about in English as well, then maybe,
maybe it's just like purely
unique to our culture and our
language. And it's just like, I dunno.
It was, it's just been,
it's just been really weird.
It's it's made me think about
things I've always took for
granted in my life where like
language was just me conveying
an idea.
And I just didn't realize
that me speaking English meant
that I was learning a part of
the history that our country
has been through. You
know, that's just, it's,
it runs way deeper than
I gave it. Any credit.
- Men discovers language.
- I can see why people
get into like linguists.
I didn't get it either at first,
and I'm just like, literally.
- Just talking about linguistics.
- The longest time I'm like, wait,
so what are you studying linguistics.
- That. I'm like, do
you know how to speak?
What'd you need to know.
- One more. Is that a learn about it?
But now I understand I'm like,
it runs so much deeper than
just, I know a lot of woods,
you know?
- Yeah. It makes me in some
ways, cause I, you know, I'm,
I'm floating whilst obviously
I lived there all my young
adult life, I guess.
Oh yeah. No child life before.
And you know, in some ways I'm like, yeah,
I think I'm I'm I know the culture.
Of course I know the culture
and I'm like, wait, wait, wait,
what exactly is it again? I'm like,
I'm like sometimes I think, oh man,
it's kind of hard to define it.
It's kind of hard to explain
anything in some ways I'm just
like, yeah, it's like the UK,
but like way more friendly,
like that kind of, it just the
culture like first similar,
but friendly I guess. And,
and more focused on being
expressive. It's not until.
- You look at it through like a.
- Third person perspective.
I feel like sometimes dare say it's like,
it's almost easier to, to,
to look at a culture and its
totality when you're not a part
of it. Yeah.
Yeah.
Because you can kind of like
disconnect yourself from it.
Sometimes whilst I'm like
something like explain most
cultures to me, I'm like, ah.
- Yeah. That's, what's so hot.
It's like, is it actually part
of that country's culture?
Or is it, what is it just your experience?
- I think through that
culture. Right, right.
That's what I, I don't, you know,
and obviously something my
experience different to someone
else. And so there would be cultural.
- Would it be easier to
describe Welsh culture?
If the other person
spoke Welsh, you think.
- It would probably be a good way
to kind of hash things out?
I be like, think about this.
This is what you say. This is,
it's one of those things
where it's like, I, you know,
getting a cultural, you know, hearing,
if I explain Welsh culture to you,
it could be totally different
to how someone else.
- Yeah.
I feel we've experienced that
quite a few times on this
podcast where we'd say
something, oh yeah, yeah.
All Australians like this, and then--
- Every type person is just
happy to like be recognized.
So it's just like, okay,
I'm not gonna call me out.
- Yeah. There's no enough
profitable to even the,
that like don't even
watch so much trouble,
but don't a lot of them don't speak.
- But it's always been
fascinating whenever I've like
experienced my perspective
of like Australian cultural,
Japanese culture.
And there've been people on
the other side watching our
show, being like, no, that's this year.
And it kind of opens my
eyes being like, oh yeah,
maybe it is just me.
- Did you get accused of
being a fake Australian?
I think we spoke about this before.
Sometimes I've been accused so
many times fake Walsh online
that I, why does he sound English then?
What have an English accent?
How does that happen?
- I think at one time, in an episode,
I said that all Australians
own passports and a bunch of
Australians will like,
But all of my friends did.
- Oh yeah. I mean,
you also have a lot of international
friends as well. Right.
- Just different crowd.
So then that's when I realized
I'm like, oh, it's not.
- Actually just integrate
it as hopefully as well.
The higher income,
the more likely you are to
having a passport because
obviously it's a luxury to travel.
- Yeah. And I mean,
my view of England is a very
skewed from a lot of people's
view because I've only really
grown up in the south. Right.
- From like the south, it's
like the rich Poppy's okay.
For the ball. That does well for itself.
North is.
- Yeah. I mean, I, I mean back,
it took me like until like 24,
25 before I even went
beyond London, basically.
- This is like all the UK though.
Don't go above London.
I know that. It's like, oh,
I've done well suited
to fields and Schiller.
- But to me,
like the Midlands was just
this urban legend that people
would make up. Right.
I'm just like Midlands
doesn't exist. It's just,
it's all the north. It's all the north.
- It just sounds like a Lord of the rings.
- You call it the north in, in Australia.
Do you have like the north section?
- No, we have, we have the coast and not.
- The, this is a great debate in the UK.
Where does the north begin?
- Because there's unfortunately,
there's no big ice.
- Walls. People in the Midlands,
people in the Midlands,
Midlands wall,
people in the Midlands where
they live in the middle,
they don't wanna be in the
north because the north has bad
connotations Pura, you know?
So a lot of people will
debate where the north is,
but I believe there was a
census of where the north is and
it's not a line.
It's this weird diagonal
line that goes from like,
I can't remember where
it's, it's a very weirdly,
almost vertical line.
It's closer to being
vertical than is horizontal.
If I remember correctly, I don't know.
It could be like 45 degrees.
It just goes like this.
That's why we went.
Some people say you're not
from the north from Wales.
And it's like, no, no, no.
But, well she's well she's north about
if you've got a Wells, it's the door, bro.
Like, you haven't been to that.
You would know.
- Isn't the latitude
wise. It's like the same
as most of the Midlands?
- Looks like.
It's like almost same where
I'm from is almost the same
latitude as Liverpool.
And that kind of area.
That seems pretty north.
I think I would say it's
from my understanding.
- Of where Liverpool
is in my map, it seems.
- Pretty good. It's pretty up there.
I don't know. To me
it's like Birmingham is,
you could maybe argue
as north, but bubbling.
It's pretty Northern as
well. I'd say, I don't know.
- I've met more people from
Birmingham that would claim that
Birmingham is not from the north.
No, we're from the Midlands Midlands.
- That's an old.
- Man. I think we're Austin, Australia.
I'm going.
- To kill the saying that.
- I think for us in
Australia, it's more so about.
Cause the Mo the majority of
the population lives on the
coast line. So for us, the
argument has always been,
where does the coast,
like the coastal cities stop
and starts becoming the inland
cities and like, no, one's
been able to figure it out.
Yeah. Because like, I think
for people on the coast,
the coast seems a lot more
narrow than it actually is.
- I think I read something ages ago.
There was something
like in most countries,
like if you don't artificially
create a border like Eastern
west Germany,
it'll almost always become
like a north south divide.
Rarely becomes a, and even
if it's not geographically,
a north and south divide,
it's called the north
south divide will weird.
I don't know why I put
this. Bring more to it.
I just didn't read the rest of it.
I think about a lot of countries
with divides of like, well,
it's like Germany has a north
south divide with like Bavaria
being a rich pop Germany in the south of.
- Italy is like.
- That as well. Has it?
France is like that too.
A lot of countries are
like that, North America,
most European countries.
- Like that. I don't think.
- America is like that.
There's like the south Southern states.
- I was thinking about
America seeing east.
- And west coast.
- It's like everywhere divided. Right?
- Everyone's killing.
- Americans, like a quad dog.
- I guess kind of a little bit.
- Japan is like Tokyo,
Kyoto and everywhere else.
- No, a weird place.
- Japan actually is east and west.
- No, it's not.
Okay.
And combo. Yeah.
But then also I would argue
in some ways it's north of the
south, because that's the
whole, a whole like Hertz,
electrical grids being different.
That's but it's like cut
off from like totally Tokyo.
- It's like a 45 degree angle.
- Tokyo upwards. And then to
the east of it, but it's up,
it's doing like this way. It's going up.
So it's a kind of south kind
of goes to the south. Yeah.
Also, how did that happen?
Oh,
it's something to do with one
side of Japan wanting to do
European way and the other,
just wanting to do its own way.
And for some reason,
I dunno why Japan still
has the whole 5,060 heads,
which by the way,
when you're filming stuff is
really inconvenient because you
have to change.
You have to remember to change
your camera from 50 to 60
Hertz. Otherwise, when we go
to a place and we'll record,
there'll be, the
flickering will be insane.
Like I filmed a crane game in Sendai,
but I think that's also on 50.
But then I think we filmed
something when we went to
Hiroshima, which is 60.
I think one of us,
we got to change one of the
GoPros and the GoPros is like,
just unusable because it
was just like strobe. Yeah.
It's just like, how does
this happen in such a,
but in other ways, I'm like, this is,
of course this happened to
Japan because I mentioned the
bank system. Of course
something stupid, like phase.
- Out the floppy disks.
Oh God. Once something is decided here,
that's just the way it's gonna be.
There is no turning back. There is no.
- That's all, that's all weekly
complain about Japan bit.
Welcome. You're welcome.
Complained about America with complainant.
- Even talked about anime.
The bingo card is full.
- Music.
I don't know. I, you know,
I think I love talking about
the differences between
countries so much,
but it also becomes like
a tedious to a lot of the
listeners. Maybe.
I don't know. I just, I just, I just,
I definitely think that growing
up cause I've traveled a
bunch and I was very,
very fortunate that I've traveled a bunch.
I definitely learned a lot
about other countries. My,
my dad lived in Germany mostly.
So it was really cool getting
to learn about all these
different cultures,
obsessed with U us culture.
But sometimes it's really
hard to talk about it online
because sometimes someone
living in that culture was like,
no, yeah, you're wrong.
But I also wanna give it a
little talk about it to be
educated, but I would argue
that that's on that person.
Right. Because it's like,
well, yeah, obviously, okay.
If I say something very
skewed perspective, it also,
if I say something
blatantly wrong, then yeah.
I mean like France is a
good country. You know,
like if I say that, then
that's fair enough that I'm,
you know, I'm joking, I'm joking.
I'm British. We make the joke.
You can move to the UK. Go for it.
- Yeah. No, but like, I feel
like especially now that now,
now that living in another country,
like probably living in another
country and integrating into
its society. I mean, this is the first,
this is my first real experience
trying to integrate into a
society where I have not grown up in.
I have no prior experience in.
It's just been a shot in the dark.
I give you guys props for
that. It is, it is a learning.
It's hard because he was
different from me living in
Thailand because I'm just
like, yeah, I've never,
I've never properly
lived in Thailand before,
but it's got like family,
their family that I've
visited there. Enough.
I speak the language.
I understand the culture
as we've just said.
So it's it's, it was much
easier for me to integrate.
And there wasn't as many surprises.
I wouldn't say I got like a
culture shock per se. I dunno.
What is culture shock?
- Culture shock is when
you go to a country
and you realize that
something that you didn't
think is normal is normal in Wisconsin,
or like the daily norms that you did,
our normal normal rethink
the way you think.
Okay. Okay.
Okay.
I guess maybe we've had culture shock,
but not like the UK reverse
culture shock. Yeah.
I had more question to you, boys.
Do you find yourself more
critical of your home country
after leaving south country? Yes.
Yeah. Okay.
it's really easy for me to
look at the UK and be like,
what a mess.
But I knew it was a mess. I lived there,
but it was your mess.
It still is my mess. I still love it.
I still love the UK, but
holy, what the are we doing
right now in the UK? There's this?
There's this, this is
like no truck drivers.
Like no two people talking
about the fuel crisis.
They it's not that it's that
we have no truck drivers
because we stopped letting
immigrants into drive trucks.
And so then it turned out
that we were only hiring
immigrants to drive tracks before.
And then suddenly they were like, ah,
who's gonna drive the trucks.
And so now there's no,
there's no truck drivers.
And all of a sudden now
they're like, we should've,
we should've thought about this.
Sorry. Then I'm not
commenting on all that.
Cause it's a minefield. But
there was this, there was this.
Now there was this there's
this news thing on BBC.
So because there's no truck
drivers, what they've done.
Oh, I dunno if this is just like,
this could have been just
news bait or something.
I don't know what it was, but
this clip was just so funny.
I don't care if it's true or not.
There was this BBC a bit about
how now they were recruiting
prisoners who had truck
licenses to drive trucks.
But then they, that like,
they're like meet Steve.
This is Steve. He's a,
he's a truck driver.
And he was in bed.
Steve C was arrested for
smuggling cocaine on a truck,
into the UK. It's could they
not have, like, I get it.
I get it. I do.
He's a great truck. I was like,
this man is really good
at driving. I was like it.
And I was like, that's trying
to sell the public on this.
And that is the one example
they give I'm like, come on.
People are not gonna be
happy with that. People like,
people don't wanna Pablo
Escobar managing that
infrastructure. You know what I mean?
Like Steve, he ran over
70 people with a truck.
The problem was that
it was delivered food.
That is people being like
immigrant truck drivers.
man. It's like, it's
like, you can't make this.
Like they wouldn't bother a
guy who like broke the law,
then get them, get someone
who can't speak English.
Well, you know what I mean?
It's up. And I know that's
this whole politics.
I don't, I don't give a.
But that, that, that whole
thing is just absurd.
But it was just that the humor
of it was just the reason why
faddish so funny. She said we
should deliver through that.
Traditional BBC, no opinion,
no emotion vibe where it
was just like the British
government has resorted to
hiring inmates to try and trucks.
This is Steve. He was caught
smuggling cocaine on a truck.
It was just like, this is so
not even a single emotion,
this thing. And it was just so jarring.
And Chris sent me the clarity.
It was just terrifying.
I was like, this is so funny.
It's just all my God. What is going on?
The absolute state,
the state of truck drivers
in the UK stay in the UK.
Oh my Lord. BBC went downhill
since can't let that.
- That's that's. I
mean, that's why I left.
Right. I got off all those stories.
- They reported that the best,
most funniest way they could have.
I was very happy with that.
- Sometimes it's just the
way they like BBC news.
It's just sometimes the way
they present it. So how can,
what's the word?
- The cold months,
gold standards of not inserting
opinion in terms of at least
just the, the broadcast airing.
And like when they factually presented,
they have a lot of articles
that are absolute with full
opinions of garbage. But yeah,
generally the prime time TV,
when they're just saying the
thing, normally it's good.
It's good. It's a good example
of how it is then normally
recently,
because the got the BBC was
a kind of a gold standard and
television and it was, and that's kind.
- It.
- Was.
- That's gone down hill when they reported
that a Gundam as a
transformer, I was like, that.
- Was the final.
- Salvo was the final straw. Couldn't.
- Even make the research to
call it a Gunda. I put the.
- Letter of resignation on the table.
- You know,
you know how like actors send
letters to other actors that
like your performance was amazing.
There's a God sent the letters to the BBC.
I am disappointed the.
- Absolute state of.
- This new state. What has
happened to the great to BBC.
- I wanna strike this from
my CV. So nobody ever knows.
I worked for the BBC.
Nobody ever will. The money I
would like to boycott the BBC.
I would like to rescind my
employment at the BBC, please.
- It's just, oh God, cause
you already, you, you know,
when you're living there,
you get to experience the nice
parts and, and the fun parts.
And now I only just hear about
the mess that's going on with
the news articles and stopped
my parents being like,
so the world is on fire here, you know?
And they were like, oh yeah,
energy prices went up
like 1000% or something.
They were like, the energy
bill went from like 40 pounds.
So like 500 pounds. And I'm
like, what the is going on?
And Jesus Christ.
- Yeah. I mean, like, even
like deep during the pandemic,
when I heard about the 5g
things, because I'm so bad.
I remember back back when it
started, we were just like, ah,
look at, look at all the silly Americans.
Yeah.
- British people in the UK.
Legitimately think that
crazy people only existed in.
They, they don't believe that
crazy places just in the UK.
- So crazy people exist everywhere.
I've been all these news
articles about people like Bernie
5g towers in the UK came out
and the rest of the world would
like, yo, get your, man's get your man's.
I'll just like, say my man's
man, A Japanese citizen.
- It's really bad.
It's like all the videos online
of 5g towers being torn down
or like sat on fire. Every time
I was watching, I was like,
oh, what was his Florida or something?
And then you hear a broody
thick British accent. Like,
Oh God, that's pretty bad.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
I dunno if we were just blind
to this when we were living
there, but I've always
just been exacerbated when.
- That's about five years,
it's gone lifeline it's
skyrocketed. And yeah,
it's really pretty tragic.
- I feel like, especially during
like these past few years,
we've seen like the
stupidest parts of humanity,
just like on all like on front and center.
- They don't think they think stupid.
- It's unfortunate that, you know,
our country was like
part of that stupidity.
We thought every country
thinks there and mean to it,
but we felt we soon find out that we are,
we are not in the justice.
- Any, any country with internet,
it's gonna happen to every single,
every country that has the
internet. It's unfortunate.
- Joe, do you know what I realized?
Ah, you know,
like every cheesy hero movie
or every like cheesy heroic
moment where the hero asks
the entire world to come
together, cooperate.
Like you remember that scene
in dragon ball Z where Goku
asks everyone to give me your energy,
energy for the Spiro BombBomb.
I realized that's the entirely.
Like imagine if that tried
to even imagine if that like
happened in real life, you know,
like the Americans would argue
whether they have the right
to not put that hands up. Right.
Japan would take six months
to approve any of their
citizens. Putting that
hands up the UK was started,
would start burning 5g towers
and Australia would probably
go back into lockdown.
- Ground.
- No one would put their hands up.
Oh my God. I would like,
I would like to see that.
I would like to see that Goku
seen post COVID let's let's
let's see how that turns out.
I think it would go on for
twice as many episodes. Right?
It's just like, there's
just like the bad guys.
It's like.
- Go, go cross to go on a
PR trip around the world,
kissing babies.
- Convince everyone.
- Smoke weed on.
So what you're saying is Goku.
He said everybody has to
put their hands up. Really?
Really.
- People be like, I dunno, right?
Wing thing to say, I don't
know about this margin.
Bukari so you say he's the
greatest threat in the universe?
How come I haven't heard of him?
Sounds like a hoax to me
turning the frog's game.
I haven't got any proof that he's exists,
but he's not some liberal,
some something made up by the liberals.
It's liberal propaganda.
I tell you, oh my God.
- So when someone needs to
make a political satire,
dragon ball Z, that'd be the
funniest thing in the world.
New grounds.
You need to come into the
dark ages and to make that.
- It sucks just being like, I don't give
about any of this.
It sucks being like, yo, you're all crazy.
What are you guys doing?
Just be normal.
So hard.
It's so hard to be normal
because that in itself is a take.
That's like, what do you mean?
You don't have strong opinions
on this weird that I read
online.
I don't care, man.
I'm just trying to chill, man.
I just think that like, why
don't you be nice to people?
I don't.
- Know. It must be nice to have
the privilege to just chill.
- But yeah, at the end
of the day, I, you know,
I it's one of those things
where I it's unfortunate because
I don't think inherently people,
I think there are a small
amount of people that genuinely
are like extremely hateful
in a sense. I don't think,
you know, it's why I hate
demonizing any side too much.
I don't like just saying
one side is right.
Because I think at the end
of the day, even though,
as long as they're not
posting harmful stuff,
which I'm solid, unfortunately they are,
they are posting harmful misinformation.
It sucks because I don't think
that anyone is inherently
like evil or trying to spread hate.
I think they genuinely just
believe that what they're
spreading is gonna save
people's lives will help.
Which sucks. Because then,
then when someone believes
that firmly about it,
it is impossible to.
- I th I think it's just,
it's been exacerbated by
the internet. I mean, it's,
it's like being in social media.
It's so easy just to fall
in an echo chamber, right.
Where you were, because
you think a certain way,
and there's nothing you get
exposed to that challenges you
or challenges the way
you're thinking. Right?
Because you know, in the
old days you hear something,
you hear something that you
disagree with and maybe you have
a, maybe have a debate
or, you know, maybe you,
you talk to someone about it,
but in here you can just simply mute them.
Or you can just simply not
follow people who have that
opinion.
- I think that's the problem
I have with it. It's like,
I don't really mind people
giving like extreme opinions
about things on the internet. Right.
And, you know,
believing in something that
they firmly believe in.
The problem I have is that no,
one's having a open
conversation about it. Right.
And no one is no one is
ready to be like, say,
say the opposite opinion
to me, I'm listening.
And I will,
and I will try and understand
that the best I can,
it's just like, blah, blah, blah.
I'm right. you mute.
You know.
- You know, it's, it's the incident.
It's very powerful because I
think growing up anything you
read it's in a it's in
books. It must be true.
You've been told that stuff
you read or stuff that you've
experienced. So stuff that
you're told is always true.
Yeah. So and even then
it's not sometimes, right.
Like I remember when I was like 12,
I first came across like the
moon landing. Conspiracy.
Yeah.
And like, for like a week, I've
already thought it was true.
Yeah. Because I, I read
it and I thought, well,
that makes sense.
This posting explained it
well enough to me. And then,
you know, but I was 12, I
was 13 or whatever, you know,
like, you're, you're a idiot.
You can't think about staff. You can't.
Yeah. You can't be like, oh,
maybe they cherry picture.
Like they presented information.
This all seems like it
makes sense in my world.
And that I understand. So
it it's, it's, it's tough.
And some people,
I feel like almost kind of
have that mindset going forward
and never really liked, tend to think, oh,
maybe I should look at other stuff. Yeah.
What was that?
- I've never written by the
losers or something like that
because it's like,
it takes energy and time
to look at the other side.
And a lot of people don't have
the energy and time to look
at the other side nowadays. And.
- It's just like, train
yourself to like, kind of.
- You have to go against your, you know,
your own gut feeling.
And you're just like, okay,
I have to literally go out of
my comfort zone and see what
the other side is saying,
which is why I like on
my social media. I try,
even if I don't,
even if there's someone out
there who I don't agree with,
I still like sometimes
follow them or I still like,
sometimes want them to
appear on my feet. Just so,
just so like, I know
what the other side is.
- Yeah. I do.
I do hate this idea that you
can't follow anyone who has
like controversial takes or
anything on Twitter. I'm like,
I was so war it's like, you
know, you're not promoting them.
If you're following them,
it's like, all right,
well just let them follow them.
Like, what harm is it doing?
Why would you want an echo chamber?
I don't understand this whole
process of only experiencing
your thought process and people
who think similarly to you.
I, to me.
- Surrounded by nothing. But yes, man,
that equally turns you into.
- Because someone has
committed like war, war crimes,
or genocide.
Maybe it's a little different.
But if someone just said
something that's but yikes on
Twitter, it's like, I mean, if
someone just gave an opinion,
it's tough.
I got canceled for that or
canceled. I remember they like,
he's following he's Ben
Shapiro or something.
He's he's right. Waiting bro.
Or Jordan pizza or
whatever. Like that kind of.
- I don't think that's like.
That's like the next
level of just like, oh,
you it's not even, you agree
with this person it's you are,
you have a platform where you
listen to this person, the by,
by therefore you aren't
supporting them. I'm just like,
that's.
I just wanna know what
the other side is saying,
because I think it's interesting to see,
to have a different perspective,
even if I don't necessarily agree with it.
And like, I think,
I think a big reason why I
just like don't have the energy
for like a lot of politics
nowadays or like this,
this spectrum of a mentality
is that everyone has something
to say, but everyone knows
what they stand against,
but no one knows what they stand for.
That's how I feel, where
you can like a lot.
There's so many people who
say, you can say, this is bad.
I disagree with this. I disagree
with this person and this,
I disagree with that person,
but they've never told me
what they stand for or what,
you know, what, what their
fight, you know, what,
what opinions are standing
for. And I'm just like, well,
you know what? You can,
you can discredit someone,
but you can't come up with an
argument force your own values
or your own views. And I
think, I think that's why I,
that's why, like, I don't have
the energy for this anymore.
That's why, that's why I've
started to just, you know,
I've I've I just listened to people.
I like listening to people
when I feel like even listening
to the other side of the
argument really broadens your
horizons. Even if it's
something you don't agree with,
or even if you think the
other side is stupid,
which you know, kind of
happen, certainly do it.
It does keep you grounded.
And it does help form your volt
form your worldview as well.
Yeah, absolutely.
Very eloquent.
Thank you very much. Thanks
for coming to my Ted talk.
Very eloquent. Almost like the
patrons of today's episode.
Oh my godly eloquent on screen
right now. Look at them.
They're not overly opinionated,
but they're also very eloquent. These,
these people would put
the hands up for Goku.
These people wouldn't
burn 5g towers, but Hey,
if you like to support the show
and then make sure to go to
our Patrion patrion.com/trashes,
also follow us on Twitter.
Send us your names on the subreddit.
And if you hurt our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
Get out charge what a good
night. Thanks for watching.
Bye bye.